I'm a regular visitor to the job center
as I am in other institutions but the
issue it raises with me is what a
privilege does this mean that the
government is now monitoring the visits
of members of this house to government
departments for use for use in political
debates because if that is the case let
me just say I have a brilliant working
relationship my local job center the
staff work incredibly hard but most of
our communication is via emails and
telephones Etc however if our visits to
government offices are to be monitored
it will no longer be emails or
telephones I'll insist on a meeting at
the tax office the job center their
Board office and every other government
agency in my constituency this is a
matter of parliamentary privilege Mr
Speaker I'd like you to look into the
matter
can I first of all say I Thank The
Honorable gentleman for notice at that
point of order the incident he recount
is indeed surprising and I have note
that the leader of the house has heard
it we will leave it there for now but I
will follow upon it punch water yes
Dharma thank you Mr Speaker the prime
minister's comments on Tuesday night to
his back benches were briefed to
journalists by his spokesperson
those comments were reasonably
interpreted by several media Outlets
including the Daily Telegraph as being
criticisms of the Archbishop of
Canterbury and the BBC for their
comments and coverage of Ukraine
government ministers were out on
broadcast rounds yesterday morning and
they didn't seek to correct that
interpretation but Mr Speaker since then
the government has corrected the record
and said the prime minister's comments
only referred to the Archbishop and not
the BBC so I'm more than happy to Echo
that correction and withdraw my comments
of yesterday
right before we begin
foreign
before we begin I believe it would
assist the house if I remind members of
the decision in question and the
procedure on this motion
the decision before the house is whether
or not to refer the matter to the
committee of privileges at this time it
will be for the committee to report back
on whether it considers there has been a
contempt
whilst it is perfectly in order to The
Honorable members to question diversity
of the prime minister's responses to the
house cited in the motion it is not in
order to challenge more generally the
truthfulness of the Prime Minister or
any other honorable or right honorable
member good temper moderation must be
maintained in parliamentary language
much of which
we might be said today has already been
said in response to the prime minister's
statement on Tuesday previous debates on
such motions have relatively short since
2010 the longest such debate has been
for one hour and 29 minutes and debates
have been as short as some minutes that
said an amendment has been selected and
this motion of great importance the
debate may continue for as long as it
takes unless either a successful closure
to bring the debate to an end or we
reach five o'clock in which case the
debate will be adjourned to a future day
I would also say if it begins to become
very repetitive we then may have to
consider whether to do a closure earlier
but I will leave that on how the debate
develops any members
any members wishing to speak need to
stand to ensure they catch my eye and
bear the beginning of this debate
so the right to remember for Holburn and
Saint Pancras has tabled a motion for
debate on the matter of privilege which
I've agreed should take precedence today
inform the host that although I have
selected the amendment in the name of
the minister for the cabinet's office I
understand it is now the intention of
the government not to move that
Amendment
sure
so now we will start by calling here's
Thomas to move the motion
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker I beg to move the
motion in my name and the other names on
the order sheet for today
Mr Speaker the motion I've tabled seeks
to defend the simple principle that
Honesty integrity and telling the truth
matter in our politics
that is not a principle that I or the
labor party have a special claim to
it's a British principle it's a
principle that's been cherished by
conservatives for as long as their party
has existed
embraced by unionist and nationalist
parties alike and one that still guides
members from every political party in
this house
I will
it um remember lead opposition leader
giving way
I lost my mother to covet in the first
lockdown
it was a very painful experience because
she was in a hospital bed we obeyed the
rules we could not be by her side when
she passed
I have made my disquiet known to the
Prime Minister a couple of times now and
he has taken that on board I am deeply
unhappy at the way number 10 has
performed over this period in question
but what I would suggest to the right
honorable member is that It's Perfectly
Natural in this country that you weigh
all the evidence
before deciding on intent because the
central issue here is whether the Prime
Minister misled Parliament would he
agree that
in us all accepting that it should be
referred to the Privileges committee
that committee needs to weigh all
evidence before coming to a decision and
that concludes the Sue gray report
just say to others interventions are
meant to be short what I would say and I
do say to us if you're intervening and
you are on the list you will go aloud I
know the honorable members not and
obviously wouldn't want to know he's
made his speech Yes
uh can I just first say I'm sorry
I'm sorry for the loss within your
family and we all send our condolences I
know how difficult it has been for so
many during this difficult period
um in relation to the substantive
intervention just two points and I'll
develop them later the first is there is
already a case before the house that's
um very clear the Prime Minister said no
rules were broken 50 fines for breaking
the rules and the law have already been
issued so there's already a reasonable
case under the motion because I do
understand the sentiment behind the
intervention if the motion is passed the
committee will not begin their
substantive work until the police
investigations are complete so that they
will have all of that evidence before
them one way or the other in order to
come to a view and I think that within
the body of the motion and that's the
right way and the way it should work and
I hope that does address the concerns
that have been raised
I will
I think I'm gonna wait and further to
that point that The Honorable gentleman
across away many of us in the chamber
have uh lost loved ones over the last
period of time and we feel greatly
aggraved that we haven't had the
opportunity to um uh have our our day in
court if I swear to put it perhaps we do
feel the need to have uh just a sing for
all those who have lost loved ones those
who who passed away and who we miss
greatly uh does say right honorable
gentleman Phil when it comes to Justice
why we do need to see all of the
evidence they're also at the end that
day has to be accountability in this
process and accountability means people
have to answer for what their actions
have been
well again can I express my disciples at
the loss that he and his family have
endured and I I was struck particularly
just a few months ago in the way that
um he spoke about that
um in this house I think we all were but
on the substantive points and this is
really the point of the motion this is
about honesty integrity and telling the
truth in this place and it's important
principle and it's one we all share as I
say I'm not claiming this as a labor
party principle it is a principle that
we all share because we know the
importance of it that's why it's a
matter
um for the house to consider but it is a
principle under attack
because the Prime Minister has been
accused of repeatedly deliberately and
routinely misleading this house over
parties held in Downing street during
lockdown
now that's a serious allegation
because if it's true it amounts to
contempt of Parliament
and it's not and it should never be an
accusation that is made lightly
and nor should we diminish the rights of
members to defend each other from that
accusation
but the prime minister's supporters
don't seek to do that instead many of
them seek to Simply dismiss its
importance they say the reverse crimes
he didn't rob a bank he only broke the
rules for 10 minutes it was all a long
time ago
every time one I will in just a moment
every time one of these arguments is
trotted out the status of this house is
gradually eroded and our democracy
becomes a little weaker
because the convention that Parliament
must not be misled and that in return we
don't accuse each other of lying
a not curious quirks of this strange
place they're fundamental pillars on
which our constitution is built
and they're observed wherever
parliamentary democracy thrives
with them our public debate is elevated
when members assume good faith on behalf
of our opponents we can explore test
interrogate our reasonable disagreements
about how we achieve our common goals
because ultimately no matter which
benches we sit on no matter which whip
we follow fundamentally we are all here
for one reason
to advance those common goals of the
nations of the peoples that make up our
United Kingdom and our giveaway
to the leader of the opposition for
giving way and he mentioned
some of the arguments around well it was
just nine minutes well I met a woman who
was a daughter of a serviceman he lost
his life the week before that birthday
party and she said to me what I wouldn't
give
for just nine more minutes with him I
congratulate him on the way he's Rising
above Party politics here but to just
diminish nine minutes as just anything
it diminishes us all across both sides
of this house would he not agree
well I'm grateful for that intervention
because it goes to the heart of the
matter because some have
try to suggest that a short period
or there's some equivalence between
these penalty notices and speeding and
that just doesn't understand the
enormity of the difference it's very
rare that the whole of the nation goes
through something together a trauma
together that was covered
and the the awful cases of funerals of
weddings that were missed of
parents who didn't see the birth of
their children and they're awful cases
but I think almost every family was
marked during this period
including my own by things that we
didn't do
that we would have liked to have done
usually visiting elderly parents
seeing children and there was a huge
sense of guilt
that we didn't do it including in my own
family
guilt that because we followed the rules
we didn't do what we thought was
actually right by our elderly relatives
and that's why it hurts so much and
that's why anybody trying to say this is
just like a speeding ticket doesn't
understand
what this goes to politically and
emotionally
and the I wasn't just one moment but
just going back to the principles
because I want this debate to be about
the principle because I think this is
where the debate should be the committee
will have will be charged if this motion
goes through in determining actually
whether there was any misleading but
this is about the principles that we all
care about and that's why I actually
think that everybody should simply Vote
for This motion this evening to uphold
those principles because those
principles that we don't mislead the
house
and in return we don't call each other
Liars in this house they ensure they
ensure I will in just a minute they
ensure that we make good decisions and
avoid bad ones it's what our makes our
democracy grow in ways that reflect the
hopes and tackle the fears of those that
we represent it's what makes our
democracy Thrive it's what makes this
house Thrive it's what makes Britain
Thrive and Mr Speaker we don't have to
look far to see what happens when that
faith is lost and there is no hope of
Reason resolving disagreements when
nations are divided when they live in
different worlds where their own truths
and their own alternative facts
democracy is then replaced by an
obsession with defeating the other side
those we disagree with become enemies
the hope of learning and adapting is
lost
politics becomes a blood sport rather
than a quest to improve lives a winner
takes all politics where inevitably
everyone loses out I will give way and
then the league of the opposition was
big-hearted enough to say earlier that
he unwittingly misled the house I'm sure
he'd agree with me that it's very
important that we stick with the
convention that we don't cause call each
other lies there's a good reason for
that two of our colleagues who've been
killed there's been a lot of attacks on
colleagues so in this debate
can we just accept that everybody here
is an honorable member and when they and
when they speak here they may
unwittingly mislead the house but they
think that they were for instance
abiding with the rules so can we tone
down the whole nature of this debate
[Applause]
thank you for that intervention and I I
will try to keep within those parameters
and Elevate this to the principle that
we're actually discussing today which is
the principles that we apply when we're
debating in this term but I will give
behind I'm very grateful to uh my friend
for giving way and also for what he's
said about the fact that we don't on
this side have a monopoly on truth I
think it's a very important Point that
he's made there but does he agree with
me that there's something really
fundamental about this and that is
whether we as members of parliament are
fit to hold these powers that we have in
terms of holding people to account or
whether the politics will always get in
the way and it was very disturbing to
hear that um because it was a labor
chair uh conservative members might vote
against it and that's very disappointing
The Honorable member for Rhonda felt he
had to step down but that principle that
either we have an independent or we do
it ourselves is is very important here
well I'm grateful for that intervention
and and it is very important we do have
these procedures to
um hold us all to the rules of this
house and it's very important that they
are applied in the right way
um with the right principles I will give
way um because I said I would once more
and then again here
well to him for giving away he's making
a very powerful speech on the point of
press
me that there is a bigger Point here
about parliament's governance structures
that our whole system of checks and
balances is completely out of date it is
beyond ludicrous that the Arbiter of
whether or not the ministerial code has
been broken is the person who's accused
of breaking it in this instance the
Prime Minister does he agree with me
that we also need a wider look at those
governance structures which at the
moment are simply not fit for purpose
yeah absolutely for that intervention
because I do think it's a very serious
point because a lot of our conventions
and rules and traditions are based on
the principle of Honor on that people
members of this house wouldn't other
than inadvertently mislead the house and
that's why the rules are set but they're
set on that proposition and if if there
is a member of this house whoever that
is
that doesn't abide by those principles
those honorable principles then that
tests or stress tests the rules that we
have I'll take one more information and
then I will give away
I I understand completely the position
The Honorable gentleman opposite said
about Tony down the rhetoric I
completely understand that but
let me let me just
I understand that position but let me
make this point because I don't know the
honorable gentleman over the years we
can't tone down the seriousness of this
matter
I was in the prime minister's
constituency earlier this week it's the
neighboring constituency to mine the
London bar of Harlingen we're
campaigning in the elections and yeah
there is some shift in vote from Corey
to to labor because of the decision but
that isn't a significant issue the
significant was the number that we were
finding
totally disillusioned now who'd had
enough of this system were blaming the
system itself
that's what we're fighting for here this
is what we're campaigning for here we're
campaigning to restore The credibility
in the Democratic processes of our
country
yeah and I'm grateful for that
intervention I think it's a really
important and Powerful point because if
we don't pass this motion if we don't
take this opportunity to restate the
principles then we are all complicit in
allowing these standards to slip we're
all complicit in allowing the public to
think we're all the same nobody tells
the truth
um there are alternative sets of facts I
I will in one minute I've given way a
lot and I do want to make some progress
but I'll try and come back to the
honorable member but because the
conventions
I'll make some progress and I'll try to
come back to people where I can
um the conventions and the Traditions
that we are debating this morning are
not an accident they've been handed down
to us as the tools that protect Britain
from malays from extremism and from
decline
and this is important because the case
against the prime minister
is that he has abused those tools
that's the case against him but he's
used and protect himself rather than our
democracy that he's turned them against
all that they are supposed supposed to
support
um and members opposite know that the
Prime Minister has stood before this
house and said things that are not true
safe in the knowledge that he will not
be accused of lying because he can't be
he stood at the dispatch box and Point
Blank denied raw breaking took place
when it did yeah
and he did so as he did so he was hoping
to gain extra protection from our good
faith that no prime minister would ever
deliberately mislead this house he's
used our faith our conventions to cover
up his misdeeds
because
I'll just finish this point because
after months of denials of absurd claims
that all the rules were followed of
feigned outrage and his staff discussing
rule breaking we now know the law was
broken
we know the Prime Minister himself broke
the law
and we know that he faces the
possibility of being found to have
broken it again
and again
and again
because the police investigation is
ongoing we don't need to make final
judgment on the prime minister's
contempt of parliament today
when the time comes the Prime Minister
will be able to make his case he can put
his defensive Corsican he
can make his case that
his repeated misleading of parliament
was inadvertent as his defense that he
didn't understand the rules that he
himself wrote he could make that defense
that his advisors at the heart of
Downing Street either didn't understand
the rules either
or misled him when they assured him that
they were followed at all times
or that he thought he was worth at a
work event
even while the empty bottles piled up he
could make those defenses
he can make those defenses when the time
comes but Mr Speaker I will in just a
minute
we already know he has a case to answer
the Prime Minister said no rules were
broken
but over 50 fines for breaching the
rules in the law have now been issued
including to the Prime Minister and
anybody who denies that simple fact
has their head in the sand or is given
up any interest in the truth given up
interest in the traditions of our nation
in order to prop up a law-breaking prime
minister now the motion today would
refer the matter to the committee for
privileges a committee that has a
government majority
so no one can say the prime minister is
not being judged by his peers
the committee would only investigate the
Prime Minister for contempt once the
police have concluded their
investigation
so no one can say there is Prejudice to
the rest of the inquiry
and of course any findings the committee
comes to any sanctions they might
propose would then come back before this
house as a whole
so no one can say it's too soon for the
house to decide
it is a system of self-governance and it
should be because with the great
privilege that comes with sitting in
this place
comes the great responsibility to
protect the conventions that underpin
our democracy I will give way
I'm grateful to The Honorable member for
giving away on conventions does he also
agree that language is equally important
and therefore would you take this
opportunity to distance himself from The
Honorable member who spoke earlier on
who said that he wanted to Lynch another
honorable member of The Honorable member
who sat right next
who's on this side tari scum he should
distance himself from them
[Applause]
that's a shame I actually thought we
were having a reasonably serious debate
Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
I'll just say honorable lady she needs
to sit down in furnace to the member in
charge he's given a lot of interventions
but I certainly don't need to stand up
and waiting to catch somebody's eye good
stuff
Mr Speaker
that comes into a shouting match
we we lose the principle which is there
to defend all of us all of us including
all the members opposite we're not
claiming a principal to support these
benches and not those benches it's a
principle that supports all of us and if
we fail if we fail and I I will take
that intervention yes of course
the leader of the opposition is quite
rightly just said that it affects
everybody in this house would he accept
that at this very moment in time there
is a complication which is that the
committee on standards report which is
currently being conducted under the
Aegis of the surlist rider
recommendations does raise questions
about whether or not it is possible at
this juncture to have a fair trial of
natural Justice that is currently under
discussion that is currently under
discussion within the house and the same
will apply in regards to the question
the committee on privileges which has
itself already been criticized I was on
The Joint Committee myself and I can
assure the need of the opposition there
are serious problems which arise in
relation to the need to rectify those
omissions in the procedural of fairness
I'm grateful for that interventions and
I I've heard that Casey puts on natural
Justice now a number of times and of
course he has every right to make that
case I disagree
but that's the point of the debates we
have
um but that debate about natural Justice
or due process doesn't need to hold up
this process this motion can pass today
should pass today and frankly everybody
should support it passing today to
uphold the principles and I don't think
that this there is a discussion about
natural Justice an interesting debate we
will take different views on this
um but that doesn't need to hold up this
process I will give way and then I'll
make some progress
he's quite correct to prosecute the case
on the basis of principle but there are
still in the order of people even if the
government is not going to move it now
an amendment which would indicate that
not everybody in this house shares his
view about the importance of these
principles so does he share my view that
at the conclusion of this debate there
should be a division so that we know
where every single member of this house
stands in to this principle because at a
time like this on an issue like this
there should be no hiding place for
anyone
I'm grateful for that intervention and I
agree because
um we have a duty here today in relation
to this motion and relation to these
principles and if we fail in our duty
the public will not forgive and forget
that we have done so because this will
be the Parliament that failed
failed to stand up for honesty integrity
and telling the truth in politics
failed to stand up to a prime minister
who seeks to turn out good faith against
us and fail to stand up for our great
democracy
and it's not just the eyes of our
country that are upon us it will also be
the Judgment of future Generations who
will look back at what members of this
great house did when our customs were
tested when its Traditions were pushed
to Breaking Point when we were called up
to stand up for honesty integrity and
for truth I move the motion Mr Speaker
yes
the question is I was on the order paper
I now call the father of the house sir
Peter bottomly
part of this is about the Prime Minister
my habit over 46 years has not been to
make a public or private comment about a
party leader whether mine or somebody
else's and don't propose to change that
now but I have something to say to a
prime minister I say to them directly as
it first with Hal Wilson and I've done
with most other Prime Ministers since
then
my preference
would be to go with the amendment but
it's not going to be moved I can't
I think this is not the right time for
the house to make a decision I think the
words of amendment are ones that I would
support and I'm sorry that the husband
be able to consider them and maybe the
minority in supporting that but that's
not a problem in this house that's what
a lot of people do
yeah second thing is I think the words
in the third paragraph of the prime
minister's statement on Tuesday
spell out the situation that he didn't
think ineffective as a party or the
rules being broken he now accepts that's
been judged by the police to be
different he's accepted that I don't
believe we should build a great big cake
on top of that admission acceptance like
the house would be better to leave it
like that and we'd better also no one's
thank you it would also be better
not turn to you Mr Speaker if the house
decided that the reference to privilege
committee should be made when all the
information is available from the
cabinet office report and from the
results of the police investigation
the last thing I want to say is that
without attacking young member ilford
those who heard the today program this
morning heard the repeated reference to
the local government elections on the
5th of May
I believe that whatever the leader of
the opposition says some part of what's
before the house today is
straightforward attempts to get positive
disadvantage I I intend to have no part
of that
I now come to the leader of the SMP Ian
Blackford
thank you Mr Speaker I think on a day
like this we think of all of those that
made so many sacrifices over the covered
Pandemic those that lost
so many loved ones and our thoughts and
our prayers today
are with each and every one of them
Mr Speaker there is one reason why it is
so important that this motion is debated
and passed today
because
at the very heart of the Scandal
there is one thing that needs to be said
one thing that needs to be heard and
it's the very reason
that we all need to act
and the reason is this
that the prime minister of the United
Kingdom
is a liar
I genuinely don't say that lightly and I
don't say it Loosely I honestly believe
that it's right that we are slow to use
that word
but I equally believe that it is right
that we should never be slow to see it
and to call it out
when it is so obviously true
because members across this house know
it to be true and the public have long
known that and that is why it needs to
be said today and why we all need to act
because Mr Speaker
every single day in this chamber there
are motions that come before this house
which are complex and nuanced
and there are usually two sides to an
argument and valid Reasons from
whichever position is proposed
but I think we can safely say that this
definitively isn't one of these debates
the evidence of the motion
speaks for itself
it's as Cletus day if there ever was an
open and shock case this is it
Mr Speaker
last December
the Prime Minister came to this house
and denied that there were any parties
in 10 Downing Street during the long
covered lockdowns typically and
tellingly he hid behind his staff in
seeing it
he told us that he was given firm
reassurance
that no parties had happened
that no rules had been broken
saw it
with their own eyes
and shamefully
to this very day
it is still on the record of this house
but we know the truth
and the contrast contains nois
no Bots and no maybes
Mr Speaker
the house was misled and sober the
public
and we were all misled
deliberately because the Prime Minister
knew the truth not only were parties
happening Not only was the law broken
the Prime Minister was at the very
parties he denied had even happened
the truth is simple and it's this
he lied to avoid getting caught and once
he got caught
he lied again there is no other way to
describe it there is no other word for
it
now Mr Speaker
I can understand that this may be a
terrible Truth for the government
benches to hear
but it's a truth that they need to hear
and it's a truth they need to live with
and I say to the father of the house who
I've got the utmost respect for this has
got nothing to do with any elections
this is about the behavior of a prime
minister an office
and much more importantly
the uncomfortable truth that the prime
minister of the United Kingdom is a liar
is exactly why they finally need to act
and remove them from offers and other
prime ministers
including all the predecessors as
conservative Prime Ministers would have
been long gone by now
Mr Speaker
the bench is opposite put the prime
minister in power
they have the power to remove them and
the public expectant to act
Mr Speaker
we have reached this point
a motion of contempt and a sitting prime
minister is shocking but unfortunately
it is no surprise
I will happily good way I'm grateful to
my right honorable friend forgiving we
he's made an important point about the
members in the benches opposite being
here to listen and to see this and
regardless of the number of Flushed or
drained faces opposite what does he say
to those who have previously called for
the prime minister to resign but now as
things have got worse have changed their
position and are not here today
well I I'm grateful for that
intervention and I will come on to that
in a little bit more detail but I'd say
to everybody the Tory MPS that are here
and those that are not here for whatever
reason
is to show some moral fiber
the short backbone
to recognize what this prime minister is
doing to the very fabric of our
democracy
and today
of old days
to do the right thing
and support this motion that is in the
name of the leader of the opposition but
so many other parties in this house as
well Mr Speaker we shouldn't forget that
when the Tories put this prime minister
into Downing Street nearly three years
ago
the Tories knew no actually it was the
conservatives that elected Boris Johnson
as their leader and the important fact
Mr Speaker is that the Tories knew
exactly the kind of person
that they were putting into the highest
office in the land the newest track
record
they knew his character they knew who he
was
they knew what he was and they still
chose him as their leader
of everyone in this house the members
opposite know better than anyone else
that a trail of Scandal and law breaking
was always going to Define his time in
office
underneath three short years
unfortunately those who made those
predictions
haven't been disappointed
the sleaze and the Scandal
have been 10 a penny
from lying to the queen to illegally
protegrate Parliament the shortest
Parliament
we've got to be careful I've asked for
moderate language more temporal language
and line to the queen and bring
liquidity I'm not having being Blackford
I went to a drop withdraw I'll wait to
just withdraw that one friends in
definitely see yourself Mr Speaker I
will do so but let's not forget the fact
that the Prime Minister was found in the
highest court in the land of a legally
proroguing this Parliament
stuffing the House of Lords
as I've said at the beginning and I know
the honorable member will want to stick
to what I said it is about the terms of
what we are debating we can't go beyond
that so I know he's very good and he can
stick to the script that I've explained
that we do so here in Blackford I will I
will happily take that guidance Mr
Speaker but of course we'll reflect on
the Supreme Court there's judgment
stuffing the House of Lords with Tory
party donors VIP lanes for coveted
contracts and even dodgy donations to
decorate down industry this is who the
prime minister is it is who he has
always been as prime minister he has
done exactly what it says on the tin but
the real point is this and with every
day that passes and every day he stays
in power it is who the entire
conservative party has now become
honorable friend for giving away he's
making a very measured and Powerful
spiritual strike and of course with the
electorate in my area of all political
Persuasions who have been writing to me
calling for the prime minister's
resignation quote they are not surprised
at is the repeated behavior of the Prime
Minister the lame excuses and the
pattern repeating over and over again
what is surprising is that the honorable
members opposite are keeping him in
office why does my little friend think
that is the case
well I have to say I I hope that members
opposite listen very carefully to what
my honorable friend has said
because the power to remove the prime
minister
rest with them
hit rest with them because they can
submit their letters to the 1922
committees
they can recognize the damage that this
prime minister is causing
to the fabric of our democracy and yes
to the integrity and the honesty and the
decency of this house
it is just um
well you know here we go once again the
conservatives want us to sit down and
shut up yeah they don't wish to hear the
voices
of us that are here to represent our
constituents that quite frankly are
appalled at the way that the Prime
Minister has laughed at the people of
these Isles with his behavior over covet
so if members fought down this motion
not only are they endorsing all those
scandals and all that sleaze they are
handing the Prime Minister a blank check
to do it over again and I would be
surprised if the other were gentle
opposite me would accept the scandals
the sleaze the corruption and is
prepared to give the Prime Minister a
blank check because I don't want to if
he wants to do that it can rise and he
can explain Mr Speaker of course he's
right to be surprised because of course
I'm appalled and that's why I was
encouraging him to sit down because if
he would just let us speak he might
Advance his own course some of us some
of us actually are extremely
disappointed but I will just say well
I've got the floor he I think heard what
I said on Tuesday he's a brother in
Christ does he not believe in Redemption
[Music]
and I believe that when a prime minister
has misled the house
that he should face the appropriate
sanctions Mr Speaker I know you
understand
talks about a contrite position does he
not agree when the conservative party at
prayer attacks the very foundations of
the Church of England we should be
taking no lectures from them on being
contrite or reconciled concealers
I have to say we we've had the usual
deflection from the Prime Minister over
the course of the last few days
to see the Archbishop of Canterbury
being produced
to them the way that he was the
established church by the Prime Minister
the established church Nation to be
introduced in such a way my goodness
utterly shameful one more time
thank you for giving way and on the
issue of Christian forgiveness I wonder
if it's worth pointing out to the house
that before you can have Christian
forgiveness you first must have
confession and contrition
[Applause]
well of course
how we get confession from a prime
minister that denies everything I just
don't know
Mr Speaker I know you understand that I
couldn't let this motion pass
without a special word for the spineless
Scottish stories
because unfairly
fairness story leader it's probably the
only person in the conservative party
who finds himself in a deeper hole than
the prime minister in fact he's so far
down that political home that he
obviously found it impossible to dig his
way out and make it down to London
devote his boss out tonight now I know
and understand that plenty of people
back home are looking forward to the
Scottish story he's been giving us
straight red in the council elections in
a few weeks for most people
for most people
that's democracy
democracy
and I hope I hope the people in Scotland
are watching this because what we see
are the conservatives trying to shout
down parliamentarians in this house
that's what's happening Mr Speaker for
most people it is very understandable
and it's very understand
there's Scotland's answer from the
Tories let's shout Scotland down because
that's what they're doing this afternoon
can we just calm down I do want to hear
The Honorable gentleman and I know he
wants to get back on track he doesn't
want to distract from the importance of
the debate in Blackfoot Mr Speaker you
know for for most people it's very
understandable that their main reaction
to the flip-flopping Scottish Tony
leader on his support for the prime
minister is disbelief and Justified
anger but I have to admit when I reflect
on the position of the Scottish Tori
leader my main reaction is something
that I know he'll appreciate far far
less
I actually feel sorry for him because
he's by no means the first person to
have his career ruined by the Prime
Minister that particular pile of people
has a mountain high by this stage
because ultimately everybody and I mean
everybody is eventually thrown under the
Boris bus yeah as we saw yesterday not
even the Archbishop of Canterbury is
safe clearly the days of the Church of
England being the conservative party at
prayer are long gone
the prime minister's party are obviously
praying to another God these days though
no doubt even that would guarantee the
salvation but in all serious Mr Speaker
that unjustified attack on the
Archbishop gives another toxic insight
into the thinking and methodology of the
Prime Minister because his mudas
operandi is very simple and it's this
when he finds himself under political
pressure find someone else to blame
anyone else just as long as he never
takes responsibility himself because
nothing and nobody else matters the only
thing that does matter is that this
prime minister will stop at nothing to
save his own skin
that is why members opposite should not
save him today
think about it he wouldn't even lift his
finger to help them so if they have any
self-respect they need to ask themselves
why should they even be contemplating
walking through the lobbies for him Mr
Speaker let me end on this point
it might surprise members as a party
that is so unapologetically seeking out
of this very institution and out of this
Parliament I actually do care of how it
acts
how it operates and the values that it
holds and I care deeply for this reason
because
today's motion
isn't just about this Parliament or this
place we should all know by now that
democracy and decency are under assault
the world over
and Mr Speaker
if we fail to defend these values and
every single institution we are part of
these values will Decay and decline it
was George Orwell who famously said that
political chaos is connected with the
decay of language
and I know that people are deeply
fearful about just how real that
prophecy has felt in the last few years
because
when language decays so does the truth
and so does trust in our politics
prime minister
can't be trusted with the truth marks
the end of that very dangerous decline
so
if today is about anything
has to be about finally ending that
decline
that the claim didn't start with this
prime minister
but it needs to end with him
because we should all be very clear of
what the consequences are of this house
fails to act today
if we don't act
if we don't stop
then this Parliament will be endorsing a
new normal in this Parliament and across
our politics
a new normal
where no one is held responsible
for no one has held to account
and who have no one
no one
ever resigns
and that is exactly why this motion
matters because it can and it will only
ever become a new normal if we put up
with it it only becomes normal
if those responsible aren't held to
account and aren't made to answer for
their actions
so I would generally ask members from
across the house but especially those
members opposite
if they have any after maintaining some
dignity and decency in public life
they should finally hold this prime
minister's account for his actions and
remove him from office they should
support this motion and they should
submit their letters of no confidence
and they should finally show this prime
minister the door
William rank
thank you for calling me so early in
this debate to deliver my sermon at this
juncture but if I may by means of Parish
notices on this day which Her Majesty
are happy
sixth birthday
it's my intention and still would be my
intention for it to be moved to vote
against the government's Amendment
I appreciate my writable friend the
chief Whip's efforts to find a way
through he is somebody we are lucky to
have in his role however we were at risk
of making a mistake
the original motion is perfectly
acceptable and allows for much of the
spirit of the amendment
for example the publication of the gray
report would be automatic upon the
conclusion of the Metropolitan police's
work there was no need to complicate
matters
the Ukraine situation is of huge
importance
but the invasion of a Sovereign Nation
by a dictatorial aggressor should not be
a reason why we should accept lower
standards ourselves
I have told the prime minister to his
face that I think he is doing a good job
robustly supporting the Ukrainian
government and Her Majesty's government
along with our nation can be proud of
their role and generosity let us give
credit where credit is due
however much as though I may have tried
I cannot reconcile myself to the prime
minister's continued leadership of our
country and the conservative party
I say this by means of context so that
everyone
particularly my constituents and
colleagues can understand my position
without hiding My Views with ever more
elaborate disguises
to those constituents who disagree with
me I appreciate their anger just as I
can the anger of colleagues however
say what you mean and mean what you say
I submitted my letter of no confidence
to our honorable friend member for
Ultraman sail west in December of last
year
I did so for the following reason
it followed the leak of the Allegra
stratum mock press conference video
in that video I believe she did nothing
wrong
she nervously laughed and sought to make
light of an embarrassing situation
is to see her crying on her doorstep
feeling the full way to responsibility
and anger of a country was deeply moving
and I felt immensely sorry for her and I
say this
I hope that she is well and that she
will be able to continue her
distinguished career yeah but what
alarmed me most
was later that evening
a press preview of The Winter covid Plan
B measures
brought forward
brought forward to try to move matters
on
now we debated those measures at length
but we can agree perhaps not on their
extent or their importance but they
nonetheless sought to compel or restrict
what people in this country could do
I therefore thought to myself if a
government was prepared to bring such
measures forward earlier in order to
distract from its own embarrassment that
the Prime Minister was no longer fit to
govern
I care deeply about my colleagues
I know that a number are struggling at
the moment
we have been working in a toxic
atmosphere
the Parliamentary party Bears the scars
of misjudgments of leadership
there can be few colleagues on this side
of the house I would contend
who are truly enjoying being members of
parliament at the moment
it is utterly depressing to be asked to
defend the indefensible
each time
part of us with us
now I have questioned my place
in this party in recent months
perhaps that's symptomatic
of a slave of our voters in the country
but I tell them firmly I'm not going
anywhere and I urge them
to stick with us at the forthcoming
elections
but for us to maintain their trust and
confidence we must be seen to do the
right thing
it is our responsibility it is the
conservative parliamentary party's
responsibility
we must stop delegating and delaying our
political judgment yeah
we each
have our own limited and imperfect
integrity
we can't keep spending it on spending it
on others who we cannot be sure will not
let us down
now I have great empathy
for all of those who worked at number 10
and in the cabinet office
they bought an immense burden and worked
in the most intense pressure
they worked hard and they made
sacrifices
and I also extend that same empathy to
my right and will friend the prime
minister
who knows more than most
the personal challenges and personal
battles that come that came from the
pandemic
but the matter before us is one at the
heart of this institution of our
Parliament
I love this place
believing it to be a place of high
ideals and purpose
what is said here matters
quite apart from the Facebook clips
about roundabouts and drains in our
constituencies or indeed the confected
anger to wind people up it should be a
place venerated by those of us given the
singular honor
being sent here
now of course it can be a pantomime a
fast turgidly boring obscure
but it should always be reasonably
honest
and this is for that I hope not naive
principle that I cannot support the
amendment and I will vote for the main
motion
[Applause]
come on Mr McDonald you've been here
longer than most people Chris Bryant
and Mr Speaker
um I warmly commend The Honorable member
for Hazel Grove on the speech
I think he did it
um with great courage and honesty and
frankly with the Integrity that I think
a lot of us have seen him show in his
chairmanship of the committee and I
think that this house knows that select
committees and the chairing of select
committees is not always easy because
quite often people come to select
committee meetings with fixed views
they're not all that interested in the
evidence that is presented to them and
they resolutely hold the same view
afterwards that they held at the
beginning of the meeting even though
they've been everything has been proved
to be quite the opposite of what they
thought but I think I know from those
who sit on his committee that he listens
to the evidence and he is a very good
parliamentarian as chair of the
committee I thought it all got a bit
religious earlier and um I felt I was
back at theological college and being
the only person I think in the house who
can actually pronounce
um Absolution on anybody
um
hahaha
girl I thought I was suddenly going to
get a new job and but um can I just
start by saying um I I want to warmly
also commend the work that the chief
whip has done this week because I think
he has got us today into a much better
place than the house would have been if
he hadn't made the decisions that he
doubtless advised by others has made
today
um I had not expected to speak in this
debate
um I'll be very straight with the house
if you see what I mean which is that it
is sometimes very difficult being
charitable to be on standards and
privileges because you get asked to
comment on literally every single member
of the House at some point I am
absolutely scrupulous in making sure
that I never comment in public or in
private on anything that might possibly
come to either of the Committees
I didn't think this matter would come to
the Privileges committee which is why I
commented on it and consequently I think
it's quite right that I recused myself I
will not take part in the um
deliberations of the committee on this
matter if the motion goes through in any
shape or form it I I think I could have
done it fairly
um we I chaired the standards committee
when we had
um the Prime Minister before us on a
different matter and we found that we
disagreed with the commission and we
found in the prime minister's favor
um but I understand that the house needs
to know absolutely for certain that the
process will be fair and so uh in a
strange way that means I can't actually
say something today
um I
oh all right
I kind of commend him for his speech and
for his thorough sense of decency but I
just wonder does he think the same
principle should apply to other members
of the Privileges committee
I will say something later about the
Privileges we committee but having
recused myself I don't think it's really
for me to tell them what to do or or how
to behave
um but but the one thing I'm very keen
on is I think that I passionately care
about Parliament I believe in Parliament
I believe in democracy it's the only way
that I can get change for my
constituents is through the Democratic
process and anything that undermines
trust income and confidence in
Parliament damages my opportunity to do
anything useful in my life at all and
which is why I always want to urge the
house to be extremely careful in these
matters of standards and privileges and
each generation of MPS has a special
responsibility
um to burnish not tarnish the reputation
of this house because we hand democracy
on to a future generation and if we've
undermined it
it may not last I just draw to The
house's attention that in this
Parliament
two MPS have been found guilty of
serious offenses in the court of law and
another two are awaiting trial
four MPS have been suspended for one day
a minister was suspended for seven days
and seven MPS have been required to
apologize to the house for breaches of
the code of conduct
three MPS have resigned their seats in
the face of convictions the independent
expert panel has suspended a member for
six weeks for sexual harassment made
another apologize for bullying staff and
found another guilty of such terrible
sexual harassment that he resigned his
seat before the sanction came to the
house
and that is without any consideration of
the matter of whether an honorable
member or right honorable member has
lied to the house
and it is not yet six months since the
Owen Patterson Saga which I don't think
really covered the house in glory
and
in a very short period of time two of
our colleagues have been murdered
and others are wearing stab vests
we have to take the reputation of the
house extremely seriously we have to
burnish it not tarnish it
um I've heard ministers argue quite
rightly that there has to be due process
I would say to the house that this is
the due process yeah yeah it always has
been the due process when there's been a
claim
um that either a member of the public or
a member of the House might have
committed a contempt of Parliament and
by lying to the house or or breaching
um the confidentiality around a select
committee report or whatever the
standard process is that it's sent to
the committee of privileges or as it
used to be the committee of standards
and privileges and before that the
committee of privileges
um so this is the due process
um and I I have absolute confidence in
the other members of the committee that
they will do a good job they will think
very carefully about as the right
honorable member for stone said making
sure that there is a fair hearing
because the court of public opinion
isn't very good at providing a fair
hearing I find
um the house should do a great deal
better
than the court of public opinion we try
to uphold the rule of law it's one of
the duties for all MPS and so I think
it's particularly important that we make
sure that there is a fair process and
I'm sure that the other committee
members will do so
I'm not sure where that was coming from
yes of course yes the numbers are with
them
an important contribution of course
mostly in relation to members of
parliament but he will know occasionally
somebody feels it necessary to use
parliamentary privilege to stay within
the house things which those outside
might otherwise sue for defamation over
can he just confirm that he will
consider whether we ought to have a
right to reply in for the public so that
if we use privilege they've got some
chance to put their side of the story
the young brother makes a very good
point and we've had some discussions
outside the chamber about this the
difficulty is I'm not sure that that's a
matter for the committee of standards
and privileges I think it is a matter
for the committee on procedure
um and and I think there is a very good
argument for putting something in place
so that there is a right of reply
um I I can't go further for reasons that
he may be aware of
um
I don't want to welcome this into that
area I know exactly what's going on and
I think we can leave that part of it
though Chris Bryan
thank you very much Mr Speaker
um the second point I was going to make
about Fair process is
um that it's actually quite a high bar
that the committee on privileges will
have to consider I mean I think it is as
the leader of the opposition said
earlier
not debated that the house was misled
I think even the Prime Minister
effectively admits that the house was
misled
um it was said that there were no that
rules weren't broken and it is
self-evident that rules were broken so
um the house was misled it got a false
impression
the question is whether that was
intentional
and the committee will have to devise
ways of investigating whether that
whether there was an intention and in
fact when
oh well I think I'll give away over
there first
meeting
find it straight
it's strictly worrying that we seem to
be in the in the position that the Prime
Minister seemed unable or uncapable of
following their own his own rules and
his own laws yet he is using rules of
this place and the processes of this
place to frustrate the course of as one
member has said natural Justice Yeah
Yeah Chris Brown well I would normally
agree with her on these kind of things
and I I sort of would have agreed with
her last night but I think we're getting
to a better place now
um I I think in a sense sometimes the
back benches persuade the front benches
of a better course of action
um I'm looking intently at the chief of
at the moment uh the government Chief
whip um look um I was just going to say
Mr Speaker but in one moment as the
Clark advised in the case of whether
Stephen Byers had misled the house on a
single occasion in 2001. in order to
find that Mr buyers committed a contempt
in the evidence session and for the 14th
of November 2001 the committee will
leads to satisfy itself not only that he
misled the subcommittee but that he did
so knowingly or deliberately as I say
that is quite a high bar but it is for
the committee to decide that I'll give
way to The Honorable gentleman and then
I will I'm very grateful
I'm grateful for the honorable gentleman
uh first of all because what he's just
said is what I was going to raise with
him because the actual requirement under
the ministerial code does say uh that
um it is open to a minister to correct
any inadvertent earliest opportunity
ministers who knowingly mislead
Parliament will be expected to offer
their resignation to the Prime Minister
the question is knowingly and I'm very
grateful for to him for making that
point clear well I think he's agreeing
with me so I was around yeah
and the only the only difference I would
have with him is that he was talking
about the ministerial code the
ministerial code is for the Prime
Minister this house adjudicates on its
rules its code of conduct and contempts
of parliament so they're different
matters this is about upholding a simple
principle around making sure that um uh
ministers speak honestly
um I would say one other thing about the
committee it is very important that the
six members of the committee are not
pressurized by anybody members may not
be aware but but the attorney general
and the solicitor general are able to
attend those meetings and are able to
take part in the deliberations but not
allowed to move amendments or or or or
vote but it's very important that the
committee is able to do its business
without being lent on by anyone
and and then the final point I'd make Mr
Speaker is it's why I think all of this
is important is because I care far more
about what's happening in Ukraine and on
the cost of living crisis
done about this
far more I've got constituents who are
in tears about their finances at the
moment they have absolutely no idea how
they're going to pay their bills how
they're going to pay the rent how
they're going to find school
uniforms and things like that they are
in tears
um and all of us have seen the horror in
Ukraine
I've been speaking for very long I said
in 2014 that if we didn't take Putin far
more seriously if we didn't impose far
more in stricter sanctions in 2014 he
would end up coming for the rest of
Ukraine so I care far more about those
things than I do particularly about this
motion today but they're not
Alternatives exactly exactly I would
argue
it may be in coming months that the
Prime Minister will have to come to this
house
and say we're going to have to change
our strategy on Russia
we may have to consider offensive
weaponry we may have to consider
British troops being put in a place of
danger
similarly the Prime Minister may have to
come to this house and say
I have to ask the British people to make
further sacrifices because the economy
is in a very difficult place and the
public finances are in a very difficult
place
you need at a moment of national and
international crisis
a leader of completely and utterly
unimpeachable moral Authority
I don't think we have that at the moment
I don't think we have that by a long
talk
but that's why these two things are
intimately connected and not separate
it's why I believe this must be referred
to the committee on privileges
thank you Mr Speaker and can I say I I
appreciate
and respect the series of tone that the
right honorable member the chair of the
Privileges Committee just brought to the
debate I respect the work that he does
as chair of the committee and I respect
for the work of the other members of the
committee too and that serious of tone I
believe is an important one that we
should try and adhere to it is
inevitable that there will be a party
political overlay to this and it is
inevitable that with the proximity of
important local elections uh party
political elements and electrical
considerations will intrude as they have
today and I'm sure as they will be in
the way that whatever is decided will be
reported later but at the end of the day
the debate that we're dealing with is
about a very serious matter and it
therefore deserves a serious taste
a gentleman referred to his past Callie
if I may put it that way perhaps I can
do the same
I'm very conscious
I'm very proud of that I was a lawyer
before I became a politician
and I'll be a lawyer after I finish the
politician and therefore I hope to
approach decisions like this from the
perspective of a lawyer and that may
cause me perhaps I can make a a little
bit progress before I give away and that
may cause me perhaps in the real sum to
be cautious but I'd rather be accused of
being cautious than be accused of acting
upon inadequate evidence or without a
full and proper process so that's the
preamble to what I'm about to say in our
giveaway of course
it's a problem not and let's assume that
the Prime Minister inadvertently uh
misled the house that from the beginning
he was not straight with us even if he
knew he was at a birthday the sing song
and with a birthday birthday cake why
did he delay it for such long time to be
straight with Parliament and isn't the
point that we're here today so close to
the local election the delay that has
been caused by he himself not by us here
on the opposition benches Robert Neal I
don't think that actually
reflects the tone of the debate they're
taking so far and if he would respect
your honorable lady although I'll touch
upon some of those pictures I'm not
going to follow directly uh down at that
route because what we're talking about
is an important and a serious matter
it's important because it relates not
just to the incidents which are reported
and I think now to some degree at any
rate accepted to have happened in number
10 Downing Street but it relates to to a
general culture and attitude and it's
important for this house because it
relates to three important things which
I certainly hold dear I hope all the
households here oh dear one is the issue
of public Trust
the second is respect up for the rule of
law and that in the context of adherence
to the laws
and the fact that the laws made by this
house must be adhered to by all equally
and can I get can I just finish finish
the phrase I'm going to finish the
phrase again it's always a tendency to
intervene while someone's part way
through a sentence and and the third
point that I wish to make is that
respect for the rule of law also means
respect for procedural fairness and
that's why I'm going to come on to uh in
a moment and now I know what a honorable
members opposite wanted to intervene
I'll do that first and then come to my
uh uh on a girlfriend
I do thank the honorable gentleman for
giving away and I've just put on the
record that he has been extremely
courteous to the young person ever since
my first appearance here I have great
respect for honorable member
I suspect that he like I and I speak as
a Scot
is a unionist and the Venture is
confronted me know that I believe in the
United Kingdom I believe in the benefits
of the Union between Scotland and
England and Ireland and Orlando and
Wales
but part of this the reason that unit
works is exactly what the honorable
gentleman was talking about is the
respect for this place and the way we do
things so my point of McDonald's is this
does he
does he think that the continuation of
the Prime Minister in office
will strengthen or threaten that
precious Union so Robert
as I will make a parent shortly I will
come to my conclusion as to the position
of the Prime Minister as I'm entitled to
as a conservative Member of Parliament
once I've had the full evidence the
importance of the respect of this
institution in the various parts of the
United Kingdom is of course well made
and I take that on board
I would also like to commend his
committee and his own role in this in
the investigation that took place with
respect to the issue of fixed fixed
penalty notices and just to note that
Council for domestic legislation is he
will remember says that there was a
great deal of lack of clarity as to what
regulations of prior to specific
situations at what times and so on as I
should refer to if I can call a bit
later the bottom line is that I'm sure
that the chairman of this committee is a
very distinguished chairman committee
appreciates in relation to the rule of
law question he's just raised it is by
no means clear exactly what the law is
on these subjects
for his observation perhaps that brings
me on to the point I was going to make
the purp the subject of the motion is of
course not it not of itself the fixed
penalty letters that was accepted by the
prime minister or any of the other fixed
Melody notices it is as is rightly said
the question of whether or not there was
a deliberate business that's the common
ground of course the fixed penalty
notices are part of the factual
background that give rise to that and he
is quite right to say that the Justice
committee was critical of the fixed
penalty regime that was wrought in on a
number of counts and in particular the
confusion that existed in many people's
minds ordinary individuals whose cases
would never be the subject of any
comment in this house or in the media of
the distinction or non-distinction
sometimes between guidance and law and
we have critical of that and we were
critical also of the use of fixed
penalty notices for what a specifically
described I think it's his work body on
the record as criminal offenses because
I did take the trouble to look again at
the regulations and the original 2000
regulations which were then amended
shortly before the incident in which we
were concerned specifically are set out
in terms that a failure to comply with a
restriction under the regulations that
creates an offense and the word offense
is specifically used in the regulation
so we should not minimize that we should
not therefore say this is a civil matter
this is equivalent to a parking ticket
it is not that's a simple question in
fact the ministry of Justice accepted
that they're in the statement which it
made at the time the regulations were
brought in and the Justice committee
when carrying out that inquiry heard
that in evidence indeed from an Overlord
or Wolfson of tridiga when he gave
evidence to us and also from sir
Jonathan Jones at QC the former a
treasury a solicitor so is in fact
common ground on equally accepted I'm
sure we'll write anyone else with
experiencing legal matters would that
within the range of fixed penalties
a fixed penalty notice of 50 pounds is
at the lowest end pretty much at the
lower end of the scale of the fixed
penalty notices were available again
something that the select committee
raised as to whether or not
um sort of level of fixed penalty
notices that were imposed were really
appropriate to be dealt with by the way
a fixed penalty but rather than five but
that's by way a background but that's
all very well
so there therefore we're dealing with
something which was an offense accepting
the fixed penalty discharges and if you
like deals with a Criminal a matter but
it doesn't change its nature so we
shouldn't try minimizing and I don't and
I will say without having
come to a final decision about the prime
minister's position that I'm profoundly
disappointed in what happened at number
10 dining Street
people were badly let down my
constituents feel badly let down
I feel personally badly let doubt by
what happened and there must be
consequences that follow from that now
what the consequence is I think anyone
would accept In fairness depends upon an
ultimate assessment of the measure of
culpability
and that's why I would prefer
both in making my own personal decision
and ultimately in the house making any
decision to wait until we have the full
evidence and information before us and
that's why I had the amendment been
table in the government's name been made
I would happily have voted for it
because I do think that full evidence
includes not just the conclusion of the
police investigations and nuisance or
otherwise any other fixed penalty
notices but also the content of the
sucre report doesn't anyone appreciate
the Sugo report is very likely to
include material which gives background
and context which goes beyond the strict
requirements of what is actually the
statement of facts if you like that go
with the fixed penalty notice so that's
why it's important to have that I've
been very generous with my time and many
want to speak but I will give way to it
am I right I'm very grateful to my uncle
and learned from forgiving way does he
therefore appreciate that what he's just
said about the Sue gray report explains
why some of us at least have been asking
time and time again for it to be
published in full unredacted immediately
and I agree with him in that respect I
think it was unfortunate I say no more
than that that the way the investigation
by the police has been handled and I say
no more than that has led to a delay
which may not have been needed in terms
of prejudicing at any ongoing
investigations so as a matter of fact I
believe it should be published in full
at the earliest possible opportunity now
I certainly agree with him or on that
point I'll give away to The Honorable
lady and then I'll move on to the next
Point Christine Jardine thank you very
much
um the to The Honorable member for
giving me and he's making a very
um sound legal argument and I
acknowledge where he's coming from but
would he agree with me that in politics
as in life very often there comes a
point
in an issue where one needs one's
closest friends
one's strongest allies one's wisest
Council
put a hand on the shoulder and say
enough
what you're doing now
is going too far
is damaging yourself in this case your
party and potentially the country
stop that is what is in the best
interest would the honorable member
agree with me
I simply say this I will speak for
myself and the advice that I give to my
friends a lot and that which I say to my
constituents and to this chamber as I
made it clear I would have preferred
that we had the sugary report as well as
all other material before we took a
decision on reference to the committee
but I would not stand in the way out of
this motion unamended and because
matters of important public interest
arise
I personally will withhold my final
decision until I do or all of that
material and you will understand Mr
Speaker that a very obvious reason for
that is for example that a course of
conduct that may very appropriately uh
attract a different judgment and
different consequences from an isolated
incident particularly if it were one
that were immediately admitted to and no
more occur so that context is going to
be really important to me personally now
they ultimately would be important to
this house and actually will be
important to the broader community and
to the country as a whole so that's my
word of portion that's why I would have
supported the amendment and I understand
and appreciate the spirit in which the
treasury bench brought it forward and
I'm not going to stand in the way of
this motion proceeding either because
there are important issues okay I will
then in due course make my final and
conclusion and when I do do that I won't
be backwards in coming forward
but also the way I've tried to do
politics of genuine calmness and based
upon the facts and the evidence because
that is what the country deserves at the
end of the day is an assessment based
palmly upon the evidence and the facts
applied to the relevant test of this
house or the other appropriate bodies
apply thank you Mr Speaker
and I'd start by going back to the
excellent speech by The Honorable member
for Ronda and he was in his concluding
remarks he talked about the economic
crisis facing our country and our
constituents and his right to put that
in the context of the debate today
because I think it speaks about the need
to have a government with a leader that
can command respect
with inflation at seven percent it's
high straight for 30 years and Rising
still
with families facing the deepest fool in
their living standards since the 1950s
with the pain of those energy bills and
those Rising food prices compounded by
the government's unfair tax Rises we
know that our constituents are facing
real hardship it's not just the cost of
living crisis it's a cost of living
emergency
and at such time the country needs to a
government that's going to be focused on
tackling that economic emergency and
crucially it needs a government that it
can trust with as The Honorable member
said moral Authority
and I don't believe this prime minister
and this government has that and believe
I believe that the prime minister's
Behavior has been profoundly damaging to
that trust
breaking the very laws he himself
introduced laws he was telling everyone
else to follow laws he rightly said were
essential to save lives and protect our
NHS
laws that forced countless families to
make enormous sacrifices
so Mr Speaker I believe it's time
conservative MPS listened to the British
people
who kept the rules and made those
sacrifices for example a small business
owner in bramel who said
whilst I had to sit and watch the
business I'd built up for 35 years
collapse
because my customers and I obeyed the
rules
the Prime Minister decided he would
ignore them my family and I will never
forgive him and those that treated us
like fools
the member for Cheadle would do well to
reflect on her constituents words when
she continued to support this
law-breaking prime minister
well this message the member for
Eastbourne from the constituent of hers
who attended his father's funeral just
four days after prime minister's
birthday party
we sat apart
we didn't hug each other
we weren't allowed to have a wake to
celebrate his life
I just came home and cried that he was
gone
when the next election comes around I
will remember
and the member for Lewis whose
constituents said my parents were unable
to attend my uncle's funeral
this pain will remain with them the
conduct and subsequent untruths of the
Prime Minister are disgraceful and only
add insult to their hurt
and that's the key Point Mr Speaker
it wasn't just the fact that the Prime
Minister broke his own laws
that he thought he could get away with
it
by taking the British people for fools
he stood at that dispatch box and told
this house and the country repeatedly
that there was no party
that all guidance and rules are followed
at all times in number 10.
the fact he thought he could get away
with such absurd claims claims let's be
honest we all knew were false at the
time in which the police have now
confirmed were false
speaks volumes
it says clearly that this prime minister
takes the British people for granted
do you think the rules that apply to the
rest of us simply don't apply to him
as a concert the member for Wimbledon
says the Prime Minister seems a Man
Without Shame and devoted to one
principle only staying in number 10. he
is disgrace to the office of prime
minister and an insult to the millions
of the electorate who played by the book
I'll give way too long
come from because I don't recognize it
I'll make sure that he does
the fact that conservative MPS have let
the Prime Minister get away with all
this until now speaks volumes about them
they could have kicked this prime
minister out of Downing Street 10 months
ago and began to restore the Public's
trust and confidence in the government
and in our democracy instead
conservative MPS have so far sorry
disappoint for them
misheard The Honorable gentleman
he has just said that I wrote something
now what did you sorry
it certainly didn't sort of start isn't
it conserved MPS have so far ducked
their responsibility
only eroding public trust and confidence
even further
the member for Cheltenham for example
once said that his red line for
resignation from the government was if
there was a scintilla of a suggestion of
unlawful action
well the Prime Minister has been fined
by the police
yet the member for Cheltenham is still
drawing his government salary
by keeping the prime minister in his job
conservative MPS have made themselves
Guilty By Association
and if they vote to know if they vote to
Kick the Can down the road again if they
vote to bend the rules let one off their
own off the hook again if they don't
hold the primers to account for his law
breaking and Lies by voting this prime
minister out
concert MPS should know that their
constituents will hold them to account
at The Ballot Box perhaps the member for
Winchester should listen to the vet in
his constituency who says if I broke the
rules and lied about it I would get
struck off
so why hasn't the Prime Minister been
struck off
lifelong conservative voters in
Guildford are saying they can't vote for
the conservatives anymore
speaker they complain about elections
the problem is Mr Speaker is they won't
hold this prime minister account the
electorate will have to hold this prime
minister to account
ant of the member for woking him tells
me that his MP and like oh oh
we're mentioning a lot of members
members constituents I hope the members
have been notified we're going to be
name checked
hello
I'm sorry I have nothing
[Applause]
so what I would say is can we know if
you're not going if I suggested we don't
know many more unless the members are
aware of it and in furnace I think it's
only for in the future we do do that
speaker I was quoting
just the point so that that
could be heard in this house here here
Mr Speaker the last 24 hours have shown
that the government is in total disarray
yeah yeah conservative MPS are clearly
too ashamed to back the Prime Minister
but still too complicit to sack him
the people each of each of us represent
know the truth
they know the Prime Minister
deliberately misled them and
deliberately misled this house
it doesn't insult to their constituents
especially buried families in their
seats
and it will be another conservative
stain on our democracy
if conservative members fail to sack
this prime minister
will leave the British people no choice
when it comes to the council elections
on the 5th of may let alone the next
general election
it will become the Patriotic duty of
every voter to send this conservative
government a message
that enough is enough by voting against
them
Mr Speaker this prime minister has held
this house and the whole country in
contempt for far too long
now it must be this House's turn to hold
him in contempt
that this matter has moved far far
beyond law into matters of deep politics
and fundamental values
and I think as we consider both the
motion and the issue at hand every last
member of this house might remember some
very very old wisdom that actually if
any of us says that we never fall sure
that we never break a rule that we never
harm someone else if ever anyone ever
says that then I'm afraid they deceive
themselves and the truth is not within
them
so I am very grateful that we live in a
society with the possibility of
redemption
the possibility of Mercy the possibility
that when somebody fulsomely apologizes
in a spirit of humility going on for
some hours that there is a possibility
of redemption and that of course is not
to excuse what has been done that is not
to defend it that is not to condone it
it's not in any way to say that what
went on was okay it would be to accept
that it was wrong and nevertheless
to forgive and forgiveness is difficult
no one should pretend otherwise
now
well I think she's going to enjoy the
rest of my speech but I will give way to
her for a moment I thank him for giving
away when we talk about redemption and
forgiveness isn't it at the earliest
Point possible rather than drawing
things out like the Prime Minister has
done and I think this is his main
problem had he come here and immediately
at least expressed his doubt that maybe
he was at something that he didn't
consider to be a party it would be
better but that he denied everything was
the main problem that we find in this
house so difficult to swallow I'm very
grateful to her and I think she will
recognize the spirit and the inspiration
of what I'm saying as people did on
Tuesday but I don't wish to be drawn
excessively into theology about the
timing of one's repentance but I do wish
to move on because I think the point I
want to make before In This Moment
is that many of us in this house I can
see members in front of me choose to
live their lives under certain commands
to love even their enemies to bless
those who curse them and yes to forgive
as they are forgiven sometimes for some
grave matters so when I sat here when I
sat here and listened to my right novel
friend the Prime Minister say these
words in the House of Commons which I
won't put back on the record people know
what he said when I read them again in
Hansard
I think this is an apology worthy of
consideration of forgiveness for what
went on because this has moved Beyond
law as far as I know no one else in this
country no one else in this country is
being investigated by the police for
retrospective offenses it's gone it's
behind them it's past but in number 10
in Downing Street they are being held to
a higher standard
they are being held to a higher standard
in ways that other members of the public
are not and I can hear members
barricking the point is that is right
what I demand is that when we set these
I'm sorry not merely Draconian but
barbaric rules on other people everybody
in the center of power should have
understood that they had to obey not
merely the letter but the spirit of the
rules and I'm sorry there should have
been no cake in number 10 no booze in
number 10 but just one moment no booze
in number 10 these things should not
have happened I do not defend or I I do
not condone in any way what went
happened and I'm spoiled for Choice I'll
give let's rate The Honorable lady
outside them in the forgiving way and I
am mesmerized by his psychic powers if
he doesn't understand that all offenses
are retrospective unless he knows
someone's going to commit an offense but
does not agree with me that to forgive
to ER is human to forgive is divine to
repeatedly transgress
as this report already shows us is
something else and isn't it important
that we have this inquiry now to
understand whether that has happened and
whether there has been a repeated
offense against us because in the last
year half of the public have lost even
what little trust they had in
politicians the longer this goes on the
more rep repetition there is all of us
are besmirched isn't it right and that
Spirit of forgiveness and Redemption
that we are all given the opportunity
for salvation Not For the First Time
Madame Betsy speaker The Honorable lady
tempts me to give her references and I
would encourage her on the point of
repeated offenses and forgiveness to
look at Romans 7. but the point she does
also invite me to clarify what I said of
course all offenses are retrospective
the point I'm making is that of the
point I'm making is the police the
police are treating Downing Street staff
especially harshly in a way that the
rest of the public are not being true
well if the gentleman wants to say it's
not true I'll take his intervention
people up and down this country who've
received Farms Way Beyond The Measure
they're imposing down in one street he's
got to get his pack straight before he
stands up and says they've been treated
more harshly that is simply not accurate
of course people up and down the country
have been fined and punished and all the
rest of it and he knows perfectly well
that I've stood here and complained
about those things far more than he has
or anybody over on that side he knows
that perfectly well the point I'm making
is that the police are going back some
months to offenses committed some time
ago in a way that they're not for other
people and I think that is accurate I
think my honorable friend the minister
was nodding along earlier and indeeding
once again so in order to move on
when I sat here and listened to these
words I was deeply moved for all that I
have said if he broke the law or
acquiesced in Breaking the Law if he
lied at the dispatch box he must go I
still felt moved to forgive
but I want to be honest to the house and
to my voters that that Spirit of earnest
willingness to forgive lasted about 90
seconds of the 1922 committee which was
it's usually I'm sorry to say
orgy of adulation a great Festival of
bombast and I'm afraid I cannot bear
these things
this level
of transgression this level of demand
for forgiveness requires more than an
apology drawing a line under it and
moving on in the way that the Prime
Minister sought to do overnight with his
interviews I'm afraid the Prime Minister
and those who advise him and I'm sorry
to be saying this on the record like
this
they need to understand that this is a
permanent Stone in his shoe for those of
us who want to forgive him we've got to
see permanent Contrition and a permanent
change of attitude a permanent
acknowledgment that people like my
constituent married for 50 years didn't
get to see his wife in a care home on
the 50th wedding anniversary didn't get
to see I think possibly just through a
window for our 75th birthday I've only
been married 25 years but I know what
that means to me what am I to say to
that man we didn't see his wife before
she died after 50 years 75th birthday
what am I to say well I'll tell you what
I could say to him I could say because I
know who he is you and I are Christian
men and forgiveness is hard and I don't
like forgiving him my spirit is much
more full of Wrath and vengeance I feel
much more Ezekiel 7 3 about this and
I'll invite anybody to look it up
I don't want to forgive him
but I do not want to forgive our prime
minister trouble is I like him and the
trouble is I helped him get where he is
I'll come back to that in a moment and
the problem is I am under a command to
forgive so the point I'm making is and
actually I'll talk about what the right
number gentle sky in lock Harbor said
when I and others went out of our way
not only to make him prime minister but
to do our bit spawn case my case
systematically to help get an 80 seat
majority we did not think that he was
going to exhibit a meticulous grasp of
tedious and boring my new rules of
course we didn't but we did know he had
two jobs he had to get us out of the
European Union which he was fully
committed to doing
and he had to defeat the radical leaders
of the labor party and he had to do an
environment where everyone was exhausted
we were testing our constitution to
destruction and the Very internal
stability of the United Kingdom was at
stake and that's the job we gave him to
do and by goodness he did do it and for
that I am thankful and for that he will
live with my thanks forever and he will
deserve to be lauded in the history
books
but the problem I have now got having
watched what I would say is contrition
beautiful marvelous Contrition isn't my
sense of it is it rather in all sense
only lasted as long as it took to get
out of the Headmaster study
and that's not good enough for me and
it's not good enough for my voters I'm
sorry it's not
and I'm afraid I'm now in a position
where I have to acknowledge that if the
Prime Minister occupied any other office
of senior responsibility if he was a
secretary of state
if he was a minister of state A
parliamentary under Secretary of
permanent secretary a director General
if he was a chief executive of a private
company or a board director he would be
long gone
the reason that he is not long gone is
because removing a sitting prime
minister is an extremely grave matter
and goodness knows people will know I've
had something to do with that too
it's an extremely grave matter an
extremely big decision and it tends to
untether history and all of us
all of us should approach such things
with reverence and ore or awareness of
the difficulty of doing it and the
potential consequences and that's why
I've been tempted to forgive but I have
to say now the possibility of that
really for me has gone I have to say I'm
sorry that for not obeying the letter
and the spirit and I think we have heard
that the Prime Minister did know what
the letter was the Prime Minister now
should be long gone Madam Deputy speaker
I certainly Vote for This motion but
really the Prime Minister should just
know the gigs are
the house will be aware that a great
many people wish to speak this afternoon
um and if we are to continue the spirit
of fairness one to the other
I hope that we'll manage without a time
limit
um so I'm testing the Integrity of
honorable members please stick to around
five minutes and that way everybody will
have the chance to participate more or
less equally if it doesn't work I'll put
on a time limit as usual
but it's called turn it on there you are
Carl Turner modern Deputy speaker I
intend to be less than uh five minutes
um but I think this is probably the most
unusual debate that I've been have the
privilege frankly to speak in since the
time that I was elected to this house
in 2010 it's unusual Madam Deputy
speaking because unlike on Tuesday of
this week when I suggested that the
electorate had already concluded that
the Prime Minister was either a liar
or an idiot I was called to order by the
speaker and perhaps the speaker was
right
but look the truth is we have good
reason to suggest that we've been misled
by the Prime Minister why he repeatedly
said that no rules were broken
he repeatedly said that no parties had
taken place he then suggested that he
didn't understand
the rules that had been written
by him
by his government
he couldn't get his head around those
terribly complex rules
and then I think Madame Deputy speaker
contemptuously
he or Downing Street the spin men and
women from Downing Street suggested that
this was
just a bit like a speeding offense
and I think the honorable member for
Bromley and chiselhurst made this point
of course it's nothing like a speedy
offense these are criminal sanctions and
in fact if you want to talk about
speeding offenses there's something
called the totting up procedures so if
you get one speeding offense it's three
pentagons if you manage to end up with
four offenses in a three-year period
your banned disqualified from driving
for a period of a minimum of 12 months
and if you're a newly qualified driver
if you're somebody who don't really
understand the news the rules because
you're new into the thing
and you get two uh speeding penalties
you are banned from driving disqualified
from driving in fact you have your
driving license
revolved addressed a speech that I was
intending to make today but I've been
there Madame Deputy speaker because
whilst I was here waiting to be called a
constituent contacted me Wendy Phillips
and she says this
I'm watching the debate
your constituent Lily cam
Tori water for over 50 years fell out
with kovid exactly two years ago
four weeks later she died in a care home
whilst the Prime Minister parted
the family feels so guilty
she was only in a care home for her own
safety for five months
we let uh down
I'm watching this in tears
I let him down
I was our voice
I persuaded her to enter this care home
for her own good
carry that guilt daily
so I printed
to members opposite
think carefully too
think very carefully about what the
decision they take on behalf of their
constituencies
look in the mirror
and look back see what's looking back
is it someone who is Honorable someone
who is not prepared to put up with a
prime minister misleading the country
if they don't
afraid to tell them that the electorate
will have already decided will make
their anger known at the next election
felisty Bakken thank you Deputy speaker
and I want to put on the record that
many of my constituents are angry upset
and hurt by the activities in Downing
Street I have heard many harrowing tales
of the sacrifices my constituents have
made
but I want to address one point the
leader of the opposition refused to take
my intervention and I want to address
what I was going to say the leader of
the opposition implied that he wanted to
rise above Party politics and indeed
that is a noble sentiment however I
dispute that that was what was happening
for two reasons
firstly I understand that a labor party
spokesman last night was briefing that
conservative MPS who did not vote for
this option would quote pay a price that
individual campaigns would be launched
against them in their constituencies
that is threatening bullying toxic talk
and I sincerely hope that that does not
happen
the second reason that I think this is
not entirely about Party politics is
that the gentleman opposite the member
for ilford South
sorry North my apologies trailed the
studios today
talking about local elections and about
Superior leadership shown by the leader
of the opposition I'd like to remind
this house that the leader of the
opposition twice campaigned for the
member for Islington North to be put
into the highest office in the land a
man who was later censured by the ehcr
for anti-Semitism and think what would
have happened had he been the leader
with the situation in Ukraine let me
tell you that is leadership that I can
do without
Caroline Lucas
very much Madam Deputy speaker
we often see the worst of parliament
certainly in recent weeks and months but
I think particularly with the speeches
by the right honorable members for the
Ronda and indeed for Hazel Grove we are
also seeing at least some of the best of
parliament this morning as well
I want to be clear about what's at stake
in today's debate because this isn't
just about parties or about cake or
about a fixed penalty notice akin to a
parking ticket
what is Up For Debate today are our most
profound Democratic principles and the
Very concept of decency and public life
leading by example versus hypocrisy
Truth versus lies and respect versus
contempt
and that is so because the Prime
Minister has sealed his place in history
as the first law breaker to have been
fined while occupying our Premiership
proving Beyond doubt that he misled this
house when he told us repeatedly that no
rules were broken
well we now know that they were broken
and broken by him
our democracy depends on the truth being
told by ministers
that is why resignation is what is
expected when this basic and fundamental
standard is not met
so this isn't about cake in a box or the
number of minutes spent at a gathering
this is about a prime minister failing
to hold himself to the highest standards
at a time of unprecedented National
sacrifice and then covering it up
this is about a prime minister holding
both Parliament and the public in
contempt a prime minister trashing
decency in public life and undermining
the foundations of our democracy
and so when last night the Prime
Minister tried to brush off the
importance of today's by debate by
saying and I quote you're better off
talking and focusing on the things that
matter
he couldn't have been more misguided
being able to trust our ministers and
above all the prime minister matters in
this place more than anything
because without it the whole edifice
collapses
Parliament has many roles but its most
important one is surely the role we play
in providing a check on executive power
through our ability to scrutinize the
actions of government ministers without
that they would be free to exercise
their powers as arbitrarily as they
pleased
yet our ability to play that role is
totally undermined if we can't trust
what ministers tell us if we can't rely
on the accuracy of the information that
ministers are giving to Parliament
if ministers can get away with
misleading answers what is the point of
asking the questions
if you hollow out the scrutiny process
because the answers could be lies you
hollow out this whole place
so if men if MPS don't launch an
investigation when the Prime Minister
has been found to have personally broken
a law which he repeatedly told this
house had not been broken it is not just
the prime minister's credibility that's
damaged it's The credibility of
parliament itself and indeed The
credibility on which our entire system
of democratic governance is built
Madam Deputy speaker this whole sorry
episode has demonstrated that
parliament's governance structures our
systems of checks and balances is in
urgent need of Reform it cannot be right
that if the Prime Minister makes a
misleading statement and commits a
contempt against Parliament it's up to
the Prime Minister themselves to
determine any consequences
Beyond ludicrous that the Arbiter of
whether or not the ministerial code has
been broken
is the person who's accused of breaking
it the prime minister it is preposterous
that if MPS wanted to recall a recall of
parliament to happen to discuss a matter
such as this it is only the Prime
Minister who can initiate it
as MPS we are unable to require
ministers to correct the record if they
mislead the house we can't compel an
investigation into such actions or
impose sanctions Madam Deputy speaker
old boys club rules that simply assume
honor are manifestly not adequate and as
a result a rogue prime minister is
running rings around us
so surely this is a moment when we must
review those archaic procedures that
have been so clearly demonstrated to be
unfit for purpose we need independent
oversight of the ministerial code we
need new mechanisms to be able to call
to account a prime minister who
deliberately misleads the house a prime
minister who in the words of the
respected constitutional historian the
Lord Hennessy of nimsfield has shredded
the ministerial code a crucial part of
which he says is the spinal cord of the
Constitution
that code includes an overarching Duty
on ministers to comply with the law and
if you've broken your overarching duty
it's clear you have an overarching
responsibility to go but our system is
broken and the glaring flaws in how the
ministerial code functions have been
recently investigated by the committee
on standards and public Life chaired by
the Lord Evans of Weird Al that
Committee reported on the importance of
high ethical standards just one month
before we found out about the rule
breaking in number 10. the chair made it
clear that our standards regulation
which relies simply on convention is no
longer satisfactory it is quietly
damning and on point the house must
urgently act on the committee's key
recommendations that and I quote ethics
regulators and the codes they enforce
should have a basis in primary
legislation and that government has a
more thorough and rigorous compliance
functions in other words we can no
longer leave this in the prime
minister's hands on the ministerial code
in particular the committee found that
meaningful Independence for the
independent advisor is The Benchmark for
any effective standards regulation and
that the current arrangements for the
advisor still fall below that bar now
that must urgently change if we are to
restore any respect for this place
in particular we urgently need to
implement the call for the independent
advisor on the code to be appointed by
an independent panel rather than by the
Prime Minister and it is vital that we
should be able to initiate their own
investigations and have the authority to
determine breaches of that code we
almost must grapple we must also grapple
with who should decide and issue
sanctions in the event of a breach by
the Prime Minister themselves the vested
interest of a rule breaker deciding
their own sanction cannot be discounted
any longer
in my final words Madam Deputy speaker I
just want to say a few words about the
situation with the war on Ukraine it is
the centrality of truthfulness to our
democracy that makes it such a serious
judgment to seek to put our Democratic
standards on hold because of the brutal
war on Ukraine as some honorable members
have said
some honorable members have suggested
attempts to corrode democracy and
promote the politics of division is
exactly what runs through Putin's war
strategy which means that is now more
urgent than ever that we have a prime
minister here with unquestionable moral
Authority the resignation letter of the
Lord Wilson of tredegar who resigned
from the government as a Justice
Minister had it exactly right the
government can and I quote only credibly
defend Democratic Norms abroad
especially at a time of war in Europe if
we are and are seen to be resolutely
committed both to the observance of the
law and also to the rule of law here
putting decency on pause bending our
rules plays into Putin's hand because
his brutal war on your crane is not just
a battle for territory it is about
democracy and is it about the rule of
law
it is also the case that we have a long
tradition as many other members have
said of removing War leaders and the
ability to change a leader during a
crisis is a strength of our system I
will
before The Honorable lady gives way I
did ask for five minutes and The
Honorable lady has taken nine
she might wish to consider whether she's
giving way or whether she might be
concluding soon
on that note I will not give way I have
not realized it was nine minutes I will
bring my my comments to a close but
simply to say again that this matter
could not be more important and that's
why it matters so much the resolution is
passed later today you're here
Danny Krueger
open by acknowledging what I thought was
a
Fair measured spirit in which the leader
of the opposition opened this debate I
thought he spoke in a fair-minded way as
have many other members and right
honorable members on all sides including
those friends of mine who have sadly
decided that they could no longer
support the Prime Minister but I want to
speak at his defense uh today because
somebody has to and uh I I acknowledge
uh in all seriousness how a bigger
mistake he made
uh of course he should apologize for it
and take responsibility uh and accept
the verdict of the police whether he was
surprised by that verdict or not
and if he lied to this house of course
he should resign
but he didn't
patently he didn't patently he didn't
break the law deliberately and so
patently he didn't deliberately mislead
this house
any more than the leader of the
opposition deliberately misled the house
when he said that the PM had slandered
the BBC and I welcome his sort of
apology that he made earlier and we can
now all move on from that mistake and
remember that only those who are without
sin should be cast in stones
so I do not minimize the importance of
this Scandal many many people are
outraged uh by what has gone on and have
written to me to that effect many are
just the usual haters who always
despised the Prime Minister but many are
the respectable tendency of our country
often conservative voters who just want
a steady decent respectable government
and I think particularly of my
counselors in devises and party members
who have written to me in despair of
what the Prime Minister has done and
they are right to want a steady decent
responsible government we don't have to
have a soap opera in Downing Street but
we do need a government and a prime
minister who can see the big picture and
make the big calls one who doesn't
always play for safety one who doesn't
always do the conventional thing that
the officials suggest one who doesn't
always think what would John Major do
so let me finish with a word about the
character of the Prime Minister who I've
known a little for many years uh and who
I have the privilege of working closely
with in Downing Street in those crazy
months in the second half of 2019 when
he and my other old friend Dominic
Cummings uh drove through the strategy
that finally got brexit done
there was a lot of smoke and noise in
those months but in the midst of it all
I saw the prime minister in Relentless
pursuit of the mission total flexibility
about the methods to be used including a
proportionate response to the tactics
taken by the other side
in their attempts to subvert the
Democratic process
the European Union saw how serious he
was at that time and it is because of
that that they finally accepted a deal
that we could also accept and the
country saw it
and they responded with a landslide
election victory for our party and I
don't believe any other leader would
have done it now none of this would
justify lying to this house but I don't
believe he did lie and those are the
reasons why I follow him in spite of
everything
in spite of his accepting a slice of
birthday cake when he shouldn't have in
spite of overseeing a number 10
operation that let the country down in
spite of some policies that I am unhappy
with I support him because he was
anointed by the people in 2019 to
deliver a great mission to unite and
level up the country
and because he can make the big calls
that are needed at this time thank you
Andy McDonald thank you
uh pleasure to follow the honorable
member from devises well I just may I
just politely respectfully point out the
difference between the approach of the
Prime Minister and the leader of the
opposition when the leader of the
opposition heard he came straight to
that uh dispatch box and amended the
record and that's what we're asking the
prime minister to do there's a there's a
huge distinction between the two cases
but Madam Deputy speaker we are at a
crisis point for our democracy
the Nolan principles provide clear
guidance as to conduct in public office
but they're being more honored in the
breach than the observance
we know that the when the Prime Minister
stood at the dispatch box and told this
house that there had been no parties and
that all guidance was followed at all
times that neither of those statements
were true they were palpably untrue and
this matters
it's beyond the Realms of credibility
that the Prime Minister could possibly
have thought that either of those things
were truthful when he said them
he's gone through his life
with the rules not applying to him
but the public have made their mind up
in opinion poll after opinion poll the
public have said very clearly that the
prime minister of our country has lied
and this sorry issue has to be resolved
direction would you agree with me that
this spoils down to trust and the motion
really refers to trust within this house
trusting a committee which reflects the
proportional balance of this house to
deal with the matter in a proportionate
way once all the evidence is in I I
wholeheartedly agree with my honorable
friend it all comes down to trust in
this in this place and as other members
have pointed out it's that trust that we
need if if leaders are going to make
important decisions about the cost of
living crisis and our interventions uh
that may be demanded of us in Ukraine as
we go forward that's why trust matters
well Madam Deputy speaker it's bad
enough that a serving prime minister has
broken the law but the public are
certain that he lied when he denied that
he hadn't broken the law and his Lane
defenses as to what he believed are now
in tatters it's therefore imperative
that the appropriate mechanisms of this
house are engaged as so expertly
described by by colleagues and as on the
ordered paper and that this Behavior be
referred to the committee of privileges
to see whether the prime minister is in
contempt at this place and indeed in
contempt of the country
I will yeah just going back to his point
about this sorry issue must be resolved
he knows I had the privilege of serving
as the cancer minister in this house
right now this house should be
discussing childhood cancers now if one
was a parent of a child with cancer I
suggest they would rather the house for
discussing that than this that is not to
minimize this that is that this issue
needs to be resolved and we need to move
on
and for that reason I will be supporting
the main motion with him I suspect this
evening what
but he's right we we all want to move on
from this but we will find unless this
issue is resolved we'll be back to it
forever until she stands as the Prime
Minister accepts the consequences of his
actions we need that leadership and
we're robbed of it at the moment that's
the entire point of course cancer with
children is critically more important we
want to get onto that but we cannot have
this issue hanging over us
um modern Deputy speaker sadly this this
wanton a disregard for the principles of
public office are part part of a a wider
malays malaise and we see it in many of
our uh public offices and I won't stray
Madam Deputy speaker to
recite them but I do plead with members
opposite to actively Vote for This
motion I'm pleased that the government
benches have made the movement that they
have thus far today but we've heard it
so eloquently described that the people
need to have trust in this place
democracy is at stake it's therefore
imperative that people come forward and
actively support this motion I'll finish
with this Madam Deputy speaker I don't
know whether you heard but on LBC there
was a heartbreaking interview of a
veteran
um this man could not contain his
emotions as he spoke not only of his own
service but also the loss of his son
serving this country in Afghanistan and
his anger at the lying of the Prime
Minister overwhelmed him he wrongly
criticized himself for sacrificing so
much for his country and felt it had all
been for nothing
people in this placement Deputy speaker
we've heard from the excellent speeches
for the members from Hazel Grove and my
friend from the Ronda and indeed Wickham
we've spoken so courageously they care
deeply about this nation and its
democracy and and it we all do and if
it's that reason we should stand up for
its integrity and reputation which I
regret to say as being trashed on a
daily basis by this disreputable prime
minister and I urge members across the
house to vote for this motion today
so William cash
entire issue and the legal status of
fixed penalty notices and what the law
really is
as I indicated in the house in my
response to the prime minister's
statement on Tuesday
remains on the table
it is unfortunately regrettably a matter
of extreme complexity and is charged
with political and understandable
emotional underpinning
for example the Justice committee have
themselves had a great deal of
importance to say in seeking
clarification of these matters of law
and the rule of law itself in this
context
the legal situation even now remains
immensely unclear and inconsistent
despite the presumptions that one
opposition speaker after another makes
that the Prime Minister has lied
this is the case in respect of this lack
of clarity and inconsistency as between
different police authorities and
different circumstances and different
locations
the Council of domestic legislation to
this house indicated in evidence that
the Justice committee as follows he said
there has been a lack of clarity as to
what regulations apply to specific
situations and at what times there is
evidence that local authorities and
police forces have sometimes
misunderstood the circumstances and so
forth
it is even very arguable that under
Section 73 of the public health act 1984
the regulations did not apply to number
10 anywhere as part of the crown estate
resolving that issue will be a massive
test even before course of law
on the question of the question of
contempt and the role of the committee
itself and the current procedures where
privileges or contempts are referred to
that committee the great constitutional
Authority Bradley and Ewing on that
subject states that the committee's
procedures have been criticized in the
Nickels report of 1999
and as I've said in previous debates in
relation to the committee on standards
and again today all this is currently
under review it is currently under
review here in this house
with sironis Rider's important report
relating to the principles of natural
Justice and fair trials before that
committee
and indeed they will need some very very
good legal advice in 1999 it was
concluded that the commission standards
should devise an appropriate procedure
to ensure natural Justice and fairness
as I exchanged
in my comments with the
current chairman of the committee on
standards all this is being currently
conducted under Southern's report
writer's report how the committee of
privileges is easily going to cope with
the situation is one thing but what is
Crystal Clear is that not to wait until
the sugary report has been delivered as
well as the conclusions of the
metropolitan police investigations will
only lead to further confusion and the
need for the committee even to have to
suspend its proceedings even before
they've begun
the question remains has there been a
contempt on what is the proper procedure
that should be applied and as it is it
fair as a matter of natural Justice in
the way in which the procedures are
currently being proposed that depends on
the evidence it depends on the facts it
depends on an understanding of the law
and the committee is going to have to
address all this before it could even
sit and make any conclusions with any
degree of competence
it's several Roberts but
oh yeah play
please confuse me listen Roberts I'm
very very grateful I'm very grateful
that you found me and just before I
start on my main points a couple of
things that I've been listening to and
the first that struck me is that the
government I think for many of us on
this side we're really aware of the fact
that the government were trying to to
pick this issue down the road with their
abandoned Amendment and it now just begs
the question really that we're two weeks
away from the local elections were they
more desperate to make sure that the
names of their MPS were not on the
record in the way that they voted and
that was their motivator and the other
thing that strikes me with the
government's approach is they live in
hope that the Public's memory is ruled
that the public memory be ruled by the
news cycle and that they live in hope
that the public interest will move on
I believe the government is
fundamentally wrong in this assumption
everybody who made a personal sacrifice
during covid will remember their loss or
their pain or their grief for the rest
of their lives it is engraven on our
hearts we are not going to forget the
government May kick this down the road
but I'm afraid that they are wrong if
they assume that they are tied up and
that their safety is tied up with the
news cycle the prime minister's Behavior
will not be forgotten
but today we have a chance to correct
the record to reinstate credibility in
our system and hold members opposite and
they need all of us to account not for
their or our misdeed only but for our
preparedness on occasion to defend the
indefensible today is a chance therefore
for all members across all benches to do
the right thing and I think our name
should be on record when we want to do
the right thing public trust in our
democratic system is plummeting as we
careen from one Scandal to another
the very reputation of our democracy and
of ourselves and the function that we
have here that we're honored with
seemingly at stake
Madam Deputy speaker 73 of the British
public are in favor of a bill that would
criminalize politicians who would
willingly lie to the British public and
that's something that my country has
been calling for calling for stronger
measures those who have banned
politicians from lying in their public
role not just over the last few months
we've been calling it for the last 15
years
we all know that we live in an age of of
public disenchantment from that same
poll conducted by compassion and
politics we learned that 47 of people
have lost trust in UK politicians over
the last 12 months and if we look back
over the momentous momentous events over
that period from the fall of Kabul to
the pandemic to the Russian invasion of
Ukraine and the cost of living crisis
what other conclusion can we draw that
we have failed in our duty to seek to
uphold the trust of the public this
sense of failure isn't just a rhetorical
Gambit a professional nicety an optional
extra for us here from anti-vaxxers to
the Putin regime when we fail to
confront mistruths we create a truth
vacuum in which division sets hold
when any truth is as good as any other
division along political lines comes to
matter more than agreement on the common
ground of facts this matters this
matters we work at an institution where
we can't call out the lies of another
member regardless of their position and
responsibility lies which are broadcast
around the country recorded for
posterity and those lies are therefore
impressed on the memories of millions of
people and we have no way of addressing
this effectively well I defer to the
Judgment of the speaker in this matter
party gate has demonstrated conclusion
conclusively that our self-regulating
system is really to question is it fit
for purpose the ministerial code has
proven not worthy of the paper on which
it was written gentlemen's honorable
Agreements are depended on a dependent
on Honor on the existence of honor and
we must do better and if we can't do
better because we make a mockery of the
public concerns by shrugging our
shoulders and accepting that's merely
part and parcel of modern politics then
we must be compelled to do better we as
legislators must legislate to uphold our
good names and by Extinction not just
our good names but the good name of
democracy itself the very efficacy of
democracy itself
and the first step that would be up to
this would be and I close here the first
step for this would be a bill
a second would be to rebuild our
political model much as Wales and our
cooperation cooperation agreement has
done so so that politics is built around
what we share
rather that which divides us honesty is
the most important currency in politics
and we have to restore it before we here
are responsible in part for bankrupting
our society
well it's understaffed
yeah much Lord have been said here today
about the police's investigation as a
result of which the Prime Minister was
issued with a civil penalty Pages
immediately and they came to this house
at the earliest opportunity if you have
a heartfelt apology not only that but
it's clear he and the government are not
opposing this movie to the privilege
commission which clearly shows that his
Contrition is right and true
let me be clear his apology was the
right thing to do
each and every single Britain across the
length and breadth of our beautiful
country has made sacrifices during this
pandemic for myself when my first
daughter was born my wife was very
seriously ill after that I could not see
my daughter for five days after she was
born because of it I made the sacrifices
all my residents meant successes even
the Prime Minister has made sacrifices
when he almost died from covert when his
own family members died he couldn't
attend the funerals as we know now I
believe all politicians should be held
to the highest standards be that the
prime minister or the lead of the
opposition or the right honorable member
of Islington North or the Scottish first
Minister all of whom have been caught
photographed in covered compromising
positions all of whom I believed should
be referred to the committee I was a
privilege to be investigated the Prime
Minister has paid the fine and
rightfully so
he has been unequivocal that he respects
the outcome of the police investigation
and to always take appropriate steps but
the central issue which I believe here
today is where the Prime Minister
intentionally misled the house and this
is the word intentionally or knowingly
fed his crew vital
now I point to an article published in
the Times newspaper on Saturday the 20th
of June 2010-20 the day after the event
in Downing Street in question
the article reason I quote Boris Johnson
celebrated his 56th birthday yesterday
with a small gathering in the cabinet
room which is soon after the chancellor
and a group of aides sang him happy
birthday before they tucked into a Union
Jack cake the celebrations proved a
brief respite after another grueling
week and so on and so forth
the Prime Minister had said that it did
not occur to him then or subsequently
that a gathering in the cabinet room
just before a vital meeting on Kobe's
Rashi to save lives could amount to
which the rules
this event at number 10 as I mentioned
was reported the next day in a national
newspaper and did not then prove
controversial
it is unfathomable that the prime
minister's team would have alerted
journalists to the event and
incriminated him if he knowingly
believed it was against the rule it does
not make sense
nevertheless the Prime Minister has
apologized and has been punished and
further in every transparency his weight
welcoming to move to the privileged
committee
I also want to talk on this notion
briefly addressed the article yesterday
also in the Times newspaper which
reported that sakir starmer had warned
Tory back Ventures they would pay a
price for blocking investigation
including personal attacks for the
support of prime minister I believe it
is outrageous that the leader of the
opposition come see on a day where we
talked about tolerance and riber
politics the less threat of bullying is
laid out against members house we all
have our own minds we all may disagree
but for threatened people I myself have
been had death threats and I know many
other colleagues have a death threats
but to try and Stoke this I find
incredibly dangerous
on bullying oh happily get white of
course Jess Phillips thank you Deputy
speaker
um threats of bullying right what we are
talking about is an electoral threat and
I have had to take to the police two
different death threats which directly
quoted words said in this place by the
prime minister of our country both of
them have had to go to the police
including people who have attacked my
office on the basis of the words of our
prime minister and when it was raised
with him he said humbug
no one should get re-abuse their job
from my point of doing yesterday a day
which about debates that I quote the
newspaper article again they'll pay a
price for blocking a pay a price for
personalized attack
personalized attack and I I feel sorry
for the defects you should not have
received this but this is using this of
course
it's the point not that we all face
abuse from being in this place and those
targeted attacks as one of the youngest
members in this chamber I fear every day
for the bullying and harassment that I
receive and those targets attacks all
they do is stalk the flames and receive
more for all of us
and indeed they do but we all should
rise above that and treat each other
with the courtesy that everyone needs to
be in a place of work because we have
sadly Witnesses the violence that this
colleagues have been exposed to and
ultimately the death of death of two
colleagues in this house
now going forward it is clear the Prime
Minister has taken three different
measures to improve the way things are
working in number 10. and I believe and
I know there are more changes to come
we've talked about Christian forgiveness
I'm a Christian myself I'm a Catholic
and this is a Christian country and
forgiveness is the core of what we
believe and what this country believes
the Prime Minister has offered his
heartfelt apology
he has offered Contrition he's come to
the house he's happy for this to go
towards that he's not opposing it he has
apologized we need to look at that
so now it is time to crack all the
priorities of our country we have an
obligation to deliver on our election
processes and I'm looking forward to
this focusing on important issues from
my constituents from other Valley
including guessing the Rwanda illegal
immigration scheme up and running as
soon as possible and winning the war
against the fascist Putin because the
Rwanda scheme saves lives defending
Putin saves lives and this government
dukovit has saved many lives in this
country
Christmas thank you madam Deputy speaker
there's been a lot of talk
there's been a lot of talk today about
ecology can I just remind the house
first of all that this is not a question
about when the prime minister is
apologized or not it's about whether he
knowingly lied to the house or not and
he hasn't apologized for that he hasn't
even admitted it yeah he says there was
no party there was no cake there was a
party but there was no cake and I can go
on persistently and consistently I
welcome those those apologies but let's
be clear what the motion in front of the
house today is I heard earlier today
from the leader of the SNP the right
honorable gentleman who reflected words
that my own are only the right honorable
member for my friend from Auburn and
Saint pancreas has said earlier about
the modus operandi of the Prime Minister
which that he leaves a trail of Chaos in
his wake and lets other people pick up
the the problems that he undertake
responsibility for the problems he has
caused and I have to say to the house
that the latest victim of that I did
mention that I mentioned it earlier is
Mr Speaker himself and the officer of
the chair because when he has to Chuck
out the right honorable member for the
leader SNP as he did recently for
calling the Prime Minister Elia he gets
huge amounts of public appropriate
saying what on Earth is Speaker Hoyle
doing why is he chucking the the right
honorable why is he talking the lead of
the s p out when we know what the game
the prime minister is up to
but the Prime Minister doesn't mind
because somebody else is taking the
criticism for that I have to say to the
house that it is not simply the speaker
who is undermining it is this house as
members have said before it is our
democratic system and the public cannot
understand they simply cannot understand
what Earth is going on where one person
again get thrown out but the person that
is the root of the problem is happy to
stay there smirking on the front bench
that is his modus operandi and it is
dragging our democratic system down now
we all make mistakes I make mistakes
I've had to correct the record myself
before now and we've heard about
apologies and we've heard about
um the Prime Minister should be in
contrite but I don't recall one occasion
when he has come back and corrected the
record not one I think there's an
outstanding
letter to him about the national
misleading claim on the national
statistics
to to complain about uh to to correct
um it sounds true on crime you said it
was falling and the bottom line is the
bottom line is that the Prime Minister
will say whatever he needs to say at
that point to get out of whatever
situation he is in with no sense of
obligation to the truth no sense of
obligation to whatever promise he has
just made and actually I scribbled down
a list before uh earlier on of just
about five or ten at occasions where he
has made promises that he's broken but I
don't want you madam Deputy speaker to
pull me up because of course today we
are specifically talking about the
occasions when he denied the party so
that that list will have to wait for
another occasion but there will but
there will be another occasion but there
will be another occasion
um and as I've mentioned earlier he is
damaging he is damaging the UK's
reputation abroad because we out outside
of this chamber our partners abroad and
our adversaries and our enemies can see
that he's that he is losing credibility
and that he is not somebody that we can
necessarily trust work with because his
word cannot be trusted that damages the
UK and it is at a time of international
crisis it is very serious I want to
finish by quoting an article that I read
in an article in the guardian by Mr
Simon Cooper earlier
um which was about the Oxford Union and
he talked about the Prime Minister a
young a younger version writing an essay
on Oxford politics or his sister's book
The Oxford myth
his essay tackle I'm quoting now his
essay tackles the great great question
how to set about becoming the next prime
minister Johnson advises politicians to
assemble quotes a disciplined and
deluded collection of Stooges to get out
the vote remember this was at the time
when he was just after he left
University
the tragedy of the stooge the quote
continued the quote from the the prime
minister in his earlier days the tragedy
of the Stooges that he wants so much to
believe that his relationship with the
candidate is special
that he shuts down the truth a terrible
art of the candidate is to cuddle the
self-detect detection of the stooge it
was prime minister's views then it is
apparently still the prime minister's
views today the British people have made
their mind up and for them the penny has
dropped I say to honorable members
opposite it is time for the penny to
drop as well search your feelings you
know it to be true
I don't know I say to them Madam Deputy
speaker that they need to search their
feelings they know it to be true this is
the manner of the Prime Minister and
today is the time to finally put a line
underneath that
Peter aldus
yeah
I'd like to make three brief
observations
firstly Mr Speaker was quite right to
decide that there was an arguable case
to be examined by the committee of
privileges that is the issue in front of
us today not whether the Prime Minister
intentionally misled the house that is
for the committee to decide
whilst in many respects this situation
is completely unprecedented there have
been similar cases which confirm that
such a referral is the right course to
pursue these are the 1947 case of Mr
Gary Allegan that in 1977 involving
vegetable modeling John Cordell and
Albert Roberts and the 2005 case of
Stephen Byers which I shall comment on
further shortly
the second point to decide on is the
timing of the consideration by the
committee of privileges the motion
states this should not begin as in a
substantive way until the inquiries
conducted by the Metropolitan Police
have been concluded whilst the amendment
which will not be moved states that any
vote should wait until the police
investigations have been completed and
Sue Gray's report has been concluded
in many respects we could go round and
round in circles as to which these
courses the right one to pursue and thus
it is welcome that the amendment is not
being moved
finally Madam Deputy speaker I returned
to the case of Mr Stephen Byers
and the manner in which that
the equivalent debate on the 19th of
October 2005 took place
the then leader of the House Jeff Hoon
concluded the debate by stating
the government support the motion
because it is necessary for the house to
refer possible breaches of the rules to
the standards and privileges committee
for investigation the government respect
the Privileges for house and we will
uphold them they are crucial to the
independence of Parliament and the
strength of our democracy
he concluded by saying I urge members to
refrain from treating the matter as a
party political question
the motion was passed without division
I acknowledge that in this instance the
stakes are much much higher
and honorable members from right across
the chamber quite rightly as we've heard
this morning hold passionate views on
this matter
but that approach Madam Deputy speaker I
would suggest is the right one for us to
pursue thank you
Neil Hamby
speaker I want to uh to start my remarks
by paying tribute to the powerful
contributions from The Honorable member
from Hazel Grove and the right honorable
gentleman from Ronda and I think the one
of the things that's come out of recent
events is that um uh owing to the the
Prime Minister and also to The Honorable
gentleman from Gordon we now have a name
for post truths the post-truth movement
Pinocchio politics and and uh and if
um this was just about the parties if
this was only about parties then
um the motion would stand very clearly
but actually it's about much more than
the parties it's about the situation and
the environment in which that happened
and every choice that we make in life
has consequences and I know more than
many that the consequences of the
choices that you make you have to live
with and while some members in this
house seem to uh want to make me feel as
uncomfortable as possible I'm quite
happy with that consequence because I
didn't come here to feel comfortable
um I came here for a very different
purpose
um but the most
compelling part and the center of this
argument is around the honorific titles
that we Bandy about in this room where
they're right honorable or honorable and
whether they actually mean anything of
substance and there needs to be
congruence to the the use of those
titles and the actions of the members of
this place that congruence is absolutely
essential
and when it comes to leadership I mean I
could probably talk about lots of
leadership theories and emotional
intelligence and all that stuff but
they're too fundamental standards about
leadership it is where the buck stops
and it is from where the tone is set
and the tone that has been set from the
prime minister is woefully inadequate
it has sullied the good name of his
office
it has tarnished the members of this
house and it has distorted the
importance of Truth across the countries
of the United Kingdom
I made some notes during the Easter
break and I headed them up because as I
started to add to them my list became
clear and the heading of that list was
what an absolute mess
and it's an absolute mess that's uh the
people are separated the people are
suffering a cost of living crisis driven
by 10 years of Tory austerity cuts to
welfare raising taxes changes to the
energy price cap where we are in
Scotland energy rich but pure poor and
pensioners have to survive on the lowest
pension in the developed world
um
we've most of us certainly myself I can
speak very clearly about being left on
hold for up to seven hours a day waiting
to get through to the home office to
deal with urgent Visa applications for
people fleeing War uh in Ukraine the
same is true for people trying to leave
the UK because they can't get their
passport application uh sorted
um this is a government without
conscience Compassion or courage and it
has absolutely lost the moral authority
to lead
this prime minister's demands and
commands are built on sand
defending him
is complicity in all of these feelings
and I want to return before I conclude
to the leadership of the uh prime
minister no one in my constituency is
surprised by his behavior
in fact the greatest insult in my inbox
is on the back of partygate
he made or this government mate a
ham-fisted attempt to distract people
and that has driven a new vein of Rage
crossed my constituency and that is the
costly people trafficking scheme which
is supposed to stop people trafficking
and that is the reintroduction of
transportation to the UK in 2022 we are
sending some of the most vulnerable
people in the world
cross to Rwanda to be processed it is an
absolute disgrace and the only thing
that this prime minister is delivering
is misery now the Prime Minister might
pull the wool over the honorable members
and members opposite and and he may be
able to use the whip to save his bacon
on this uh occasion but his merely mild
apology only damages his office this
house and it is simply not to be
believed and it is as he said not going
to cut the ice thank you
Andrew Jones
Deputy speaker when there are when there
are questions about the conduct of any
member in this place it is right for the
committee of privileges to take a look
at that case it's right to investigate
right for them to make a judgment and
it's right for that to happen whoever
the member is
that is the correct procedure for our
house it's one that's been the case for
a significant time
and if any matters of privilege come to
the house for decision a decision to
trigger an investigation it's right for
that to happen I support privileges
investigations it is our due process
I want to see more focus upon standards
across Parliament
since I became a member of parliament I
think it's seven Uh current or former
labor MPS have been given custodial
sentences one conservative one liberal
Democrat one SNP
one political party is having their
accounts investigated by the police
earlier the right honorable gentleman
for Rhonda gave a very good speech but
he detailed suspensions and other issues
that have come across uh from bullying
or harassment you know given all that it
is hard to argue that there are no
problems with standards in our politics
higher standards would benefit all
parliamentarians
and I've said earlier in the speech that
I support the Privileges investigations
I just comment upon that the
investigations require facts they
require evidence
both the motion and the amendment before
us today recognize that they both said
that the police must conclude their
inquiries before a privileged committee
investigation I was hoping that we might
actually see some consensus breaking out
across the chamber that I think that
commented obviously be fair and right
the amendment also said that the gray
report should be published before an
inquiry that also seemed right and fair
to me but now that Amendment will not be
moved
attention moves to the privilege
committee investigation itself and the
Privileges committee must have all the
evidence that they on any issue that
they investigate now I've previously
called for the gray report to be
published in full and as soon as
possible
that is still my view I recognize of
course the Met need the time and the
space to complete their work but every
effort must be made to bring this matter
to include a to a conclusion as fast as
possible
comments are being made by colleagues
when we haven't seen all the evidence I
have to say I can understand that
because I've done it myself but the time
and space must be allowed for the
Privileges committee to conclude their
investigation and colleagues should not
prejudge it
the right horrible member for Rhonda who
who chairs that committee and he spoke
with great eloquence about that uh
Workforce committee on previous
occasions has already had to recuse
himself from any investigation after
having made public comments and I do not
want to see the work of that committee
compromised
I'm not absolutely sure either Madame
Deputy speaker that all the speakers in
this debate have lived up to some of the
claims and values of its purposes as it
has progressed for example
those who were saying this has nothing
to do with the local elections and then
spend their time talking about the local
elections
let me just summarize because I'm
conscious of time uh the Privileges
committee do valuable work in upholding
standards and there is a problem with
standards in our politics
the committee's work is evidence-based
which is why we should have the evidence
published first and I want to see that
evidence published fully as soon as
possible because quite frankly upholding
standards benefits absolutely everyone
private
thank you madam secretary Speaker
many people have made references
throughout this to the collateral damage
that the uh prime minister leaves behind
in his wake and it has done so
throughout his career and one example is
before us today the play Master General
on the 9th of December in a statement in
this house on Christmas parties at
number 10 or Christmas party at number
10 Downing Street he said the pm has
been repeatedly assured since the these
allegations emerged that there was no
party and that no covered rules were
broken
well we now know that there were several
parties not just one brought party and
we also know that the rules were broken
because fines have been issued and the
Prime Minister has received one
so
part of the collateral damage is that
the paymaster general came to this house
and made a statement based on the same
information that allegedly has been
given to the Prime Minister and misled
the house now I accept he is he's done
so inadvertently but what I would ask
him is what he's done about that because
the record needs correcting and it
surely he should be investigating how it
is that he became to came to be
misinformed and to misinform the house
in that way and it's happened on too
many occasions for ignorance to be the
defense the idea that throughout
lockdown and through all the occasions
that uh these parties took place and the
rules were broken that none of the
Bright Young things that had been
invited ever thought that any one of
those events might be breaking the kovid
rules is that concern Ed conceivable
you raised a single question that they
might be breaking the rules and some of
these events were drinks events for
people leaving
they are out there in our constituents
constituencies
people were missing funerals they were
canceling weddings they were canceling
birthday parties and these people
thought it was okay to have leaving
drinks
and where are they what were they
thinking how out of touch with our
constituents can you be that you think
you can have a leaving drinks party and
that you're more important than the than
the people in our constituents
oh yeah
I think my girlfriend's making a really
good speech is a really good point I
just want to make a point about this
impact of breaking the law and how it
continues to hurt people not just that
it hurt people in the past how it
continues a constituent of mine told me
that Boris Johnson broke the law
partying with his colleagues while my
father died in a care home watched I
watched him through the window he gave
up on life because he could not have any
proper connection with much needed
family during his recovery from Astro I
think he could still be alive today if I
have been able to break the law by
having a close connection with him I
wasn't in the privileged position of the
Prime Minister well I think what my
honorable friend has just read out
speaks for itself and but I think what
she has demonstrated as many others have
demonstrated in the in the cases that
have read out that the problem starts at
the top here because these were workers
these people who are organizing these
parties wouldn't have done so if they
thought their bosses were going to be
upset and that they were going to come
down on them and say you're breaking the
rules and stop it and we now know that
at least six occasions the Prime
Minister was present at these parties so
this problem comes right from this from
this from from the top and the PM's
defense
has differed on many occasions it
started that there were no rules broken
then it was
um that uh there was a party but um it
it it was I wasn't present but then he
was
and then it was I wasn't warned it
wasn't a work stew well I don't see
anything about a work to do in the rules
perhaps so I've missed it but but uh but
but but it it cannot be that the person
who is writing the rules can
misunderstand them so fundamentally
setting that aside
if these defenses
that I didn't understand the rules I
needed them explain to me and that I was
misled at the outset that there had been
a party about but people told me there
wasn't then who was it who misled him
well
where are those people
what's happened to them
are they still in their posts have they
moved on
had they signed non-disclosure
agreements
where are these people who misled the
prime minister to lead him to
inadvertently mislead the house because
what we know is we can't have both
either the Prime Minister knowingly came
to this house and lied or other people
lied to him which led to him misleading
the house either way we need to identify
those people and know who they are but
the worst crime of all
really is to fail to feel the pain that
our constituents were feeling throughout
lockdown yeah no one who felt who felt
the agony that people were
the example that my honorable friend
just read out who could understand the
pain that those people were going
through
could have attended these events that
took place in number 10 down the street
and other places so the question for the
Tory MPS today is do you stand by the
people who felt that pain today
do you stand by them today and vote in
your The Honorable gentleman knows he
must use the word you when addressing
people Amendment
that was really implies to you too but
the the but but well will you
will they stand by the will they stand
by the people who felt that pain uh
throughout the last two years they
deserve answers unless others have
pointed out this is about
the fundamental trust in our politics so
when the Tory MPS vote today
just think about the damage that you are
doing to the trust in our political
process because the pup because the
public the public deserve better
and they should think about that before
they vote today this matter should go
before the Privileges committee they
know it so vote for it
can I just remind colleagues that we
have advised that really five minutes in
order to be fair to others is what
should be stuck to
Anthony Magnum thank you madam Deputy
speakers rather unsettling to be on what
might now be known as Rebel Rowe
um and I'm perhaps the wrong member to
follow uh the gentleman who previously
spoke because I happen to believe that
this motion is something that we should
support but I'm desperately sorry that
we're here I'm desperately sorry that
the men member for Winchester stood up
and spoke about the need for us to be
talking about cancer backlogs and the
need to treat it and that the member for
Rhonda Valley talked about the need for
us to be addressing the cost of living
I'm a new member in this place
relatively speaking and I've probably
made a perfect pain of myself to the
government over the last two and a half
years voting against him on a number of
issues but I love this place and I love
being a member of parliament I've seen
some of the best things in when in when
this house works together on cross-party
basis and when we do that out of the
lens shot when we do it in the back
rooms of this place on a whole range of
issues that matter to every one of our
constituencies and that doesn't reach
the public and it's a shame that that
doesn't happen but on the second end of
February this year I decided to submit
my letter of no confidence there's no
great Secret in that I was fairly public
about it I said I did it because there
was no point in me being here to lie to
the British public or to be lied to by
my colleagues I felt then as I do now
there is a standard that we set in this
place in the way in which we speak to
one another the way in which we debate
with one another and the way in which we
treat one another both in this chamber
and outside and in the committee rooms
as well all too often I have seen it to
be an enormous success and it works and
just occasionally I've seen it fail The
Honorable gender honorable gentleman for
Hazel Grove gave an extraordinary speech
and one that I couldn't even possibly
hope to top but he I'm afraid to say
that I'm not I'm not one of those
members of parliament who disliked being
here or dislikes being a member of
parliament every day that I see issues
and rules broken in this place only
reaffirms my belief that we have to
stand up in this place and make it clear
that dishonesty that inaction and and
misleading of the house cannot be
tolerated from anyone now when I put
that letter in I asked for changes I
asked for changes in the operation of
how number 10 was organized I asked for
changes in how the whipping system might
work and I'm pleased to say some of
those changes have come in but
unfortunately not enough and The
Honorable gentleman for Wickham who has
a religiously or not one that I have
made the point about forgive forgiveness
I do forgive the Prime Minister for
making those mistakes but I do not
forgive him for misleading the house as
I see it now the motion that's been put
forward and I'm pleased that the
government has worked with both the
opposition and this side for those of us
who disagree I am sorry
um
I'm disappointed that the motion uh that
we're putting forward now is kicking the
can down the road I welcome it I will
support it but I only think this is
going to be a hook for people to say not
yet not yet so on fine two three four or
five when do people actually decide to
act that's in everyone's individual good
conscience to decide when to act not for
me to persuade them but I have to say I
welcome this motion I'll support it I'll
look forward to its findings I know the
opposition will support its findings
whatever that may be and I look forward
to making sure that those who do come
after the prime minister in many years
to come will also learn from this at the
conventions of the house must be
respected
Russian Ali thank you madam Deputy
speaker when we entered the pandemic the
government led by the Prime Minister
rightly called on the British people to
do the right thing and protect each
other by following the law following the
rules
and it is why this affair has been so
devastating for so many of us
including my constituents all of us in
different ways have had to make
sacrifices some of us lost loved ones
and have not been able to mourn properly
because of the restrictions and that
applies to so many of our constituents
up and down the country and I know that
from first-hand experience when in our
in my own family we lost friends and
relatives and were not able to see their
family members or attend services or
bereave with family members and support
them
so today I want to highlight
a few cases of the many that wrote to me
over this affair Craig wrote to me about
his grandmother he said my grandmother
was my best friend she was admitted to
hospital on the day the first cases of
covid were identified in the UK she died
in hospital in early 20 June 2020. she
spent the vast majority of her time in
hospital alone confused with no visitors
it is terrible for us all that the first
lockdown covered lockdown will be
forever remembered as one of the worst
times of my life
I and the rest of my family closely
adhered to all lockdown advice and the
new laws put in place my Nan's funeral
took place the week the prime minister's
birthday party was held we were only
allowed a handful of people in the
service
most of our family and friends forced to
line the streets outside the crematorium
I cried while writing this email to you
reliving these memories I cannot allow
the Prime Minister and this government
to rewrite the history of the pandemic
and dismiss our Collective trauma as
just a slice of cake or no worse than a
speeding ticket the nation should not be
gaslit into thinking that the pandemic
was not so bad another considerant said
my mother was taken into hospital for a
blood test in in 2020 a week after the
lockdown began the test showed she
needed treatment before she could come
home but we were given the totally
unexpected news that she only had Days
to Live
this devastating news was made worse
because my father who was then almost 90
years of age and my three sisters and I
knew that the lockdown rules meant that
we would not be able to see my mother
again and that she would die as she did
two days later with no one from her
family with her so how do you think my
father my sisters and I felt when the
news broke of the partying in number 10
while we were adhering to the rules so
strictly I now feel even more angry when
I hear government ministers who I would
hope would have some standards of
Integrity coming forward on an almost
daily basis to say that it's not an
important matter that the prime
ministers not to blame that he has
apologized so that makes it all right I
hadn't intended to write you but where
what has led me to to do so is ministers
comparing partygate to parking and
speeding fines and the fact that the
prime minister is going to issue another
apology another full apology as though
that will make it all right for me it
doesn't another constituent said I just
wanted to add my voice to those asking
the prime minister's resignation I
buried my mother about a week before he
attended that party that broke the law
we couldn't even hug at the funeral
which only allowed 10 attendees no
political story has ever made me this
Furious I feel like I've been scammed by
my own government taken for an absolute
fool for obeying the very laws they set
if the Prime Minister can't even uphold
a standard so basic as the rule of law
what are we as a country
Madam Deputy speaker find the final
story on share is of a Health and Social
care worker she said I know firsthand
the impact Clover's had on a vulnerable
unvulnerable people on the front line
we should not be living in a country
where there is one rule for the Prime
Minister and government ministers and
another for one for another one for
everyone else these are voices of pain
amid so many messages emails cards and
letters voices of Agony and sacrifice so
many cries of pain from the British
people the British people deserve better
we Rose so magnificently to tackle the
pandemic as as the public we need to
make sure that that this motion is
supported today that's why I'll be
supporting motion and I'm glad that some
members opposite are supporting it I
hope others hear the voices of people up
and down the country and support this
motion today
Tommy Shepherd
we are all human
we are all fallible we all make mistakes
but it is a measure of our integrity and
our character as to how we deal with
those mistakes
and the British people have
overwhelmingly judged this prime
minister to have dealt with his mistakes
disastrously
overwhelmingly they believe him to be a
liar and they have lost trust and
confidence in him and that is a problem
it's not just for this government that
is a problem for the British political
system and I would caution some
conservative colleagues opposite to be
less Cavalier in trying to dismiss those
public concerns
The Narrative coming from the government
seems to be that these breaches were
just a consequence of living with the
regulations they were bound to happen
part of normal life that were happening
in all sorts of places they paid the
fine let's move on nothing to see here
Madam Deputy speaker that won't wash
first of all the great majority the
overwhelming majority of people in this
country did not breach the rules
they accepted the mandation that was put
upon their behavior often at Great cost
and personal consequence I have hundreds
of emails from constituents I wanted to
read somewhat today as well but there is
not time
but people who were unable to be present
when their children were born or when
their parents were buried they know and
they are angry at what was happening in
number 10 Downing Street while that was
being done to them
and the other reason that won't wash of
course is that many people have paid
much greater concert pay much greater
consequences for their actions than this
prime minister in fact I have a lot of
people writing to me asking how come
he's only had a 50 Quid fine and others
are being charged fines of up to ten
thousand pounds for approaches of the
rules and many people in public office
have already lost their job because of
their transgressions and they are right
to sit back and wonder why should the
holder of this one office be immune from
that consequence
Madam Deputy speaker I think that also
they suggest they they didn't really
know that the roles were free and broken
at the time that really does beg our
belief we heard from the member for
Wickham earlier and we know that he and
his colleagues inside the conservative
parliamentary party
were waging a Fierce and vicious
argument about the consequences of these
restrictions the idea that people
sitting in government offices drinking
and socializing after Iris didn't think
that they were in breach of the rules
they themselves were making is risible
and we should dismiss it I think there's
a simpler explanation for all of this I
genuinely believe that we have a prime
minister whose conceit of himself is so
great and whose sense of entitlement so
profound that he genuinely did not think
the rules applied to him and that is why
when exposed when found out at the end
of last year he did not come to this
house and offer Contrition he did not
come and say sorry he came and he
dissembled and he misled and he tried to
do everything to cover up the breaches
that had happened and that more than the
attendance of the party to my mind is
what he stands charged with today it is
not the fact it is what he tried to do
to conceal his actions that to my mind
is unforgivable but happily taken
intervention I really thank you
honorable member for a giving way and
he's making just such an excellent
speech and I I agree with him on on all
the counts of what he's saying over a
hundred and seventy thousand people have
died from covid in the United Kingdom
that means that has affected so many
friends and so many families there's
been devastating a sense of remorse for
people's loss but if the Prime Minister
was really showing his great remorse for
a breaking rules that he set surely his
actions would speak louder than his
words and that he would resign does he
agree with me
I I could I could not agree more I do
think that he should have resigned if he
had any integrity and I think it is
remarkable really that rather than get
an apology in any demonstration of
Contrition when these events came to
light
it wasn't until he was dragged Kicking
and Screaming into the light of Truth by
the criminal justice system and the
forces of law enforcement that we
actually got the apology that we had
this week and it is not enough Madam
dick is because I wanted to spend one
minute just to talk about the situation
in Scotland as well because the member
for Murray leads the Scottish
conservatives and he and his colleagues
at the start of this year in the
Scottish Parliament took I believe the
right decision they called upon the
prime minister to go but somehow
miraculously now they have been whipped
into line by central office and changed
their mind on that question and I can do
no better and comment on that than
actually quote from Professor Adam
Tomkins until recently a conservative
member of the Scottish Parliament and
had very senior conservative he says
they have now reduced themselves and
made a former position of principal look
not only empty but risible by insisting
that the prime minister is now somehow
fit for office and that being fined by
the police makes no difference the
Scottish conservatives are in terminal
decline again and this time it is their
own fault that from within the
conservative party in Scotland itself
now I know many people throughout
Britain will look with at horror at the
way in which this government has
traduced public service and denigrated
many of the democratic institutions in
their country but I'll tell you this
people in Scotland look at this too and
they see this as further evidence of our
British state in Decline and one that
does not represent their interests and
they are increasingly attractive by the
opportunity to create a new country an
independent country with a different
Constitution
so I will be supporting
in conclusion I will be supporting this
resolution today and voting for it and I
caution conservative members to do so as
well because they are right there is no
room for personal attacks in this place
or in politics but understand this
actions do have consequences and what
goes around will come right and if the
conservative parliamentary party tries
to sweep this under the carpet tries to
acquiesce in the actions of this prime
minister any further then they will pay
a very heavy political price for it
I really must once again to reiterate it
it's important to think of others in
this debate and to try to stick it is
possible to stick to five minutes I know
everybody here is capable of it so if
you could all do that everyone will get
in Jess Phillips thank you madam Deputy
speaker
um I I'm I'm sad that the member oh
there he is the member for totness is
not in his place uh because I I wish to
very much heaps and praise on his speech
and my remarks are that when before I
came to this place I had been in this
building twice before I was elected to
be here when my husband came down with
me it was only the second time he'd ever
been to London uh in fact the day that I
was elected and I came here I am I was
raised by a rebellious people I was
raised by people who make some of those
who are considered to be rebellious in
this building uh look very very tame
um and
um I came here with a chip on my
shoulder about what this place is and
what it can achieve actually I came here
with that I'm going to rip up the rule
book I think the member for Waltham
today wants to describe me as the Rizzo
of parliament
um and the
what happened was that I fell in love
with this place and what it can achieve
I fell in love with the job of being a
member of Parliament and watching as
people come into my surgeries and me
saying to them together you and I we can
try and change this law and I have never
once changed a law in this place that I
didn't do in concert with people from
every single part of this chamber I have
never changed the law on my own every
single thing that I have ever achieved
in this place I have done it with
members of the conservative party I have
done it with members of the Scottish
national party I have done it with
members of all of the parties
represented here today and that doesn't
get a view and it deeply deeply matters
and it's actually considerably more
popular to talk about how we are friends
than how much we hate each other it's
much more popular with the public than
we give it credit for
and so that is the thing that I wish for
people to see more of and spend a lot of
my time trying to talk to the public
about that element of politics and about
how 99 of people in this building came
here whether we agree by which means the
journey has traveled we all wish to
change the world for the better and I
think that that is deeply important and
the debate we are having today and I'm
afraid to say the one percent
the the very rare one percent in this
building is the is is what we're
debating today because I don't believe
that of the Prime Minister and I don't
believe that in every action since any
of this came to light now we're what
like nine months I could have had a baby
in the time it's taken the apology to
come
um that it would have been less painful
um the the the reality is is that it
along that nine months what we have seen
is is not somebody taking the actions to
desperately try and preserve the thing
that we all came here to do it has been
to desperately try and preserve his own
position
and that
that to me is Unforgivable
it doesn't matter how many times
somebody says sorry and you can bet your
bottom dollar should this have been any
one of us and I will make mistakes no
doubt about it I have made them I uh I I
accept people's apologies
the
the reality is is that had this been any
of us there is absolutely no way what
the Prime Minister has used to try and
put a pin and now we're on something
like the 700s pin in this particular
issue has ever been about trying to make
the country better
or to make the lives of his members of
parliament better to make them more
elector believe and which you know we
sort of I don't know why we've sort of
undermining talking about elections as
if they aren't a root of democracy
um has gone on today I have found that
quite weird like I I like elections
that's like the game that we're playing
that's the thing that we do here is we
ask the people what they think
that's okay
um but all along the way everything that
he has sought to do
has been about
him
he cannot answer a simple question and
you don't have to wait for a police
investigation I asked him a question
what was about four months ago now did
you go to this party in your flat on
this date and he said I can't answer
because there's a police investigation
well I'll tell you what there's a police
investigation into that and I can say I
didn't go to a party at his house that
day
there you go I wasn't at that party it
hasn't affected the police investigation
the the fact that what he has done
shows a lack of Contrition because it
wasn't upfront
it has never been upfront and it has
never been for anyone in this building
or without this building
it has always been about him
he wouldn't do the same
for a single person in this room and so
I ask you to vote for the motion
uh Dave Dugan thank you madam Deputy
speaker I see at the outset apologies
are one thing but apologies that are
made in the wholesale absence of any
form of evidenced repentance are not
worth
a button and I'm pleased to stand and
speak for the many Angus constituents
almost 100 now that I've written to
articulate their outrage at this debacle
of accountability at the feet of this
prime minister and he was always a
questionable choice to lead the
conservative party because he would
inevitably have become immediately
became prime minister under the politics
of that time the Indiscreet verbose
showmen that seemingly the conservatives
required to unlock the brics that
impasse in this place it was always
going to be a high risk strategy and
their chickens Madame Deputy speaker
have come home to rest but if the
tourists claim to have got brexit done
which in itself is a questionable
assertion that race uncomfortably with
the truth why are they so reluctant to
dispose of their one-trip Pony leader
and I say this in all Candor the train
crash of this prime minister was always
a question of when not if and if and the
reputational capital and the
Parliamentary respect that the prime
minister is furiously feeding off to
keep himself on political life support
is a function of a zero-sum game that
which he is gorging upon is coming at a
direct and equal cost to all of the
members opposite because they have their
ability to stand up for that which is
right and remove him but more seriously
it's also coming our cost to the publics
at Faith in political leadership such as
it is except I'm pleased to say in
Scotland where a Scottish story voters
including in my Angus constituency to
one look at this prime minister
whereupon tourist seats in Scotland fell
by 55 at the last election in 2019 only
two Scottish Tory MPS were present for
this debate today at all Madame Deputy
speaker they're not in the place now and
the Scottish story leader never showed
up at all
and the prime minister's vacuous claim
that he must stay in office to help with
the cost of living crisis and the crisis
in Ukraine is a grotesque contortion of
reality and history in reality the UK
government under this prime minister is
adding to the cost of living crisis with
tax increases heaped upon soaring Fuel
and food prices and in France they're in
the throes of the final throws of a
presidential election while supporting
Ukraine politics is not displaced by
conflict Madam Deputy speaker quite the
opposite in fact and in historical terms
the UK and other nations wasted no time
in changing leaders ahead of enduring to
World War so this charade is little more
than a disgraced prime minister
Desperately Seeking to attach himself to
a convenient cause to distract from his
new trademark in judicious character
but I know honorable and right honorable
members opposite get it we heard earlier
from the member from Hazel Grove is no
longer in this place and his excellent
speech highlighting the risks to
parliamentary and Democratic reputation
if the Prime Minister does not take
responsibility similarly the right
honorable member from The Forest of Dean
made his position clear in the Prime
Minister earlier this week and the
public have not forgotten
the nature and the letter of the rules
the immeasurable constraints on our
lives and freedoms during lockdown and
his other honorable right honorable
members have said it is literally
literally inconceivable that there was
any gray area over these parties or
bring your own booze UPS so the prime
minister's refusal to go
um is is beyond is is beyond acceptable
and these are due shared by constituents
up and down these ions not just in Angus
but my Angus constituent Nicola
Livingston points out in her words the
prime minister's refusal to go in the
conservative party's acquiescence and
undermines the rule of law and any trust
in political institutions the
conservative parties tawdry
self-preservation is an insult to the
nation and to the a a the behaviors we
expect from our leaders and it will be
profoundly damaging to our faith in
government at a time when it is already
dangerously low so I deeply regret
Madame Deputy speaking and closing that
the government of weekly withdrawn their
Amendment and I look forward to making
sure that we can put on the record a
position on this matter and the voting
lobbies today thanks
Diane happens
thank you madam speaker
in our Arcane system
the Prime Minister consisting as judge
and jury on himself and as other members
have pointed out this is a ridiculous
system and I'm willing to bet that the
Prime Minister will not find himself
guilty even though the Metropolitan
Police have found him guilty of at least
one
melt a breach of the coveted rules and
my guess is that there are more fines to
come
and this is a breach of rules that his
own government wrote and that he then
took to the Airways to defend
the Prime Minister Madam speaker and I
quote
sometimes seems affronted when
criticized for what amount to a growth
failure of responsibility
I think he honestly believes
that it is childish of us not to regard
him as an exception one who should be
free of the network of obligation that
binds everybody else well those are not
my words Madam speaker but those of his
former Classics Master at Eaton and it's
not hard to draw the conclusion that
these words still stand so it's natural
that we've had no proper apology to the
British people for his multiple breaches
of covered rules this prime minister is
both capable of multiple law breaking
but incapable of genuine Contrition and
this attitude of the rules has marked
his entire career both in journalism and
in this house for him to say I'm sorry
for any offense calls it's not a proper
apology for repeated wrongdoing for him
to say I was not aware of my own rules
is a defense of the ignorance which does
not stand in law
and for him to claim
I have not misled the house
all the rules were obeyed
no rules were broken is a Serial
cover-up I could use another word but I
will afraid with respect to Madam
speaker
and for the prime minister
say that there were no parties that
number 10
when 50 Financial penalties have been
handed out when he attended many of
these parties and stood Barman at at
least one of them this insults the
intelligence of the people of Britain
because the issue with the prime
minister is this
that he clearly believes that there are
one set of rules for him and his cronies
and another set of rules for the rest of
us including the electorate
fools Mr Speaker the Prime Minister was
talking about these are orders from him
and his cronies who consider themselves
to be better than the Ordinary People of
this country
boy
was is she aware that to whilst the
Prime Minister was organizing parties in
number 10 and showing complete contempt
for his own rules
working-class communities all over
Britain were in lockdown young people in
overcrowded Flats were in lockdown the
Mental Health crisis that we still have
around us was intensified by the very
strict operation of those rules on
communities and many young people faced
massive fines for organizing parties ten
thousand pounds and so on isn't it just
one law for Boris Johnson and his mates
and a different one for everybody else
my little friend makes it very important
point
we are told we must rely on the
Integrity of the benches opposite if the
rule of law is to be upheld in this
country
principle that no one is above the law
is to be upheld but even more important
if the respect that the people of this
country hold for the political system
be up half
we have to rely on the benches opposite
well we shall see
so members officers have complained on
these benches we're engaging in politics
and of course there is a political
Dimension my email box Madam speaker has
been deluged with complaints about this
matter and I'm sure I'm not alone and
I'm sure there are many members opposite
if they dare to admit it who would say
the same thing
what
prime minister has to accept that this
is not just some Westminster round that
nobody outside sw1 is concerned about
the public
Tory voting members of the public
Laban voting members of the public and
members of the public that had not ever
voted at all they've had to endure
Untold misery during his Premiership
no fewer than 190
000 people have died from covid over 1
million have long covered and so many
people as we've heard in this chamber
because of the rules we're not able to
be with their loved ones when they were
dying and these are the people the prime
minister is scorning these are the
people the Primus thinks he can get away
with are manifestly ungenuine and merely
masked apology to
and it didn't have to be
furthermore the background so this issue
is that living standards the plummeting
the NHS is in crisis the spring
statement rubs salt into the wounds
making tens of millions of people worse
off
I do not believe
that the public is in a mood to forgive
and forget
as we've heard the the Prime Minister
and his accolades like to say he only
was in the party for nine minutes very
many people would have liked to have
been with their loved ones when they
were dying for nine minutes so the
question for members opposite is very
clear
the country wants the Prime Minister
goal these benches one the Prime
Minister gone he broke the law so are
you just going to do nothing today and
in the future well Boris Johnson
sacrifices you to save himself as he is
done throughout his life and career
two quick reminders
we don't use the word you when
addressing this comes through the chair
and also
um colleagues should not refer to other
honorable members by name
Peter down
the motion we're considering the first
in the comments the Prime Minister made
in this place on first on the 8th of
December but they are simply specimens
but it could have referred to many other
occasions when the Prime Minister may
have been vaguled this house by using
the fact that no one could challenge his
veracity because of the protection
afford to turn by parliamentary
etiquette the Prime Minister has four
first of all of course the early warning
signs way back to 2019 and earlier for
example when he refused the invitation
for my right humble friend the member
for garston and Harold were to apologize
for his Dreadful spectator article which
argued that people affected by the
Hillsborough disaster were quote
wallowing your victim status
second what about his absurd claim made
on the 29th of January 2020 in this
place that the conservatives have grown
the economy by 73 they claim that relies
on data stretching back to 1997. third
the false assertion he made on the 4th
of March 2020 that his government had
provided free Hospital parking to all
comment that still stands all corrected
on the Parliamentary record fourth on
the 11th of March 2020 we are cutting
order
um I do need to remind
um honorable members that at the
beginning of the debate the speaker said
it is perfectly in order for honorable
members to question the veracity of the
prime minister's responses to the house
cited in the motion it is not in order
to challenge more generally the
truthfulness of the Prime Minister or
any other honorable or right honorable
member I'm sure you're a gentleman will
adjust his speech accordingly so on the
6th of September 2020 he stated in
relation to covert guidance there's
nothing more frustrating for the vast
majority who do comply than the site of
a few brazenly defined the rules so
these rules will be enforced by tighter
penalties his words Madam Deputy speaker
yeah
in on the 16th of December 2020 tall
house that this Christmas it's vital
that everyone exercises the greatest
possible personal responsibility this
was the same day London went into tier
three restrictions two days later there
was a party at number 10 Downing Street
unbelievable the Prime Minister promised
the house that he would publish all his
personal exchanges with say James Dyson
in relation to covid-19 contracts these
have never appeared
it goes on the list goes on
they don't actually tell us that he
follows the ministerial code and
principles to the letter he then said
the Prime Minister rather said tell the
house it is common sense for people to
wear a mask in confined spaces he was
photographed later the same day at
Wembley State stadium surprisingly
without a mask on the first of December
he stated in relation to cover that all
guidance was followed completely in
number 10. was it on the 8th of December
2021 he said I said a premises question
time
have been repeatedly assured since these
allegations had merged that there were
no party and that no covert rules were
broken now as honorable members have
said either the Prime Minister wasn't
being candid or his staff weren't being
counted so who wasn't until possibly
both he said he was Furious to see the
clip of his own staff discussing number
10 parties as though somehow he didn't
live there and he did on the 15th of
December and Downing street press
conferences he said I follow the rules
everybody across politics should follow
the rules indeed they should and the
Prime Minister didn't
And So It Goes On
And So It Goes On
and in that regard Madame Deputy speaker
what we're trying to do today is to set
and train a process that this house
really does need to look into the
concerns of so many members and more
importantly the many of our constituents
who have written to us about their
concerns and I think they deserve
answers they're not that interested in
parliamentary protocols often they just
want answers to their deeply held
concerns and questions finally Madam
Deputy speaker this house and surely
members opposite cannot allow
allegations of the prime minister's
insucient and nonchalant attitude
allegedly towards the truth to go
unchallenged we need to send a message
to the country that when all the police
and cries are being completed this house
will through its own process the very
processes that have protected the Prime
Minister from blunt assertions on the
floor of this chamber consider those
allegations thoroughly and openly and
can I say finally the mayor culpa mayor
culpa mayor Maxima Culper approach from
the Prime Minister does not wash with my
constituents
thank you ever so much Madam Deputy
speaker and a few people have said today
that this has been a very curious debate
and indeed I think it has been that's
been variously somber at times angry
reflective and even at times quasi
Village
but most of all this debate has been
necessary when a sitting prime minister
has been served with a Fame for breaking
of God that he himself said
particularly when that same prime
minister had come to this house and said
that no more had been broken it could
not be possibly ignored by this this
place and this house could have chosen a
number of things in response to what has
been presented but they could have done
of course what the government had hoped
it could have made another apology and
hoped everybody would move on but they
know that there's real anger out there
and this was never going to be enough
for her constituents it could at the
other end of the scale have the place
the Prime Minister and ended with him
having Taken full responsibility going
off into the Embers and ethers and that
would be the end of it he would go down
with this particular incident and then
he could fully move on but of course
that's going to be a matter for them and
they've seen no indication that they're
prepared to do that just now but we
haven't stayed Chosen and I think
inevitably we will this evening Madam is
because it now looks like it's going to
be passed overwhelming way to refer this
to the Privileges give it to him where I
personally find out a bit meh I think
it'll do as a reasonable start in order
to deal with some of the issues around
all of this but can I set the house I
don't think that we'll ever fully move
on from this until we fully appreciate
significance of what has happened and
the profound impact all of this has had
on Earth institutions our constituents
are genuinely upset and they sincerely
believe that the Prime Minister has lied
in fact you gov has just published an
appendable which shows that 78 of the
public think that he has in my very
honorable friendly member for Brook Sky
Ross and lacabra was absolutely right in
his speech to reach for the L word and
after 20 years in this house sitting in
these green benches I still find it
shocking to hear the L word in this
place but there's no other word that's
appropriate for all this no other word
could be used in context of what the
Prime Minister has said and what he's
done in fact our constituents would be
bewildered if we weren't using the word
that they now most commonly associate
with his behavior and we will never move
on until this government accept this now
I made my maiden speech the same day as
a prime minister back in 2001 in fact I
followed them from these benches and I
remember the speech quite clearly and in
his speech he compared himself to little
Simba putting his Mark into the huge
footprint left by the Mufasa of Michael
heseltine and perhaps we'll leave the
that reference here because we don't
want to obviously mention after
Pinocchio incident the title of the
feature film that features Simba and
so they know what this prime minister is
like they've known him for 20 years as
long as I have never found him a very
curious to shivering odd type of
character but they must have known him
better than me but they went and elected
to him as their prime minister they knew
what they were doing and this is the
ordinary prime minister this is somebody
who profoundly believes that the law is
for someone else and not for him there
is no other prime minister in history
who would think for a minute that they
could possibly survive having been given
a fine for breaking a law that he
himself said but the main question is
did he mislead this house no I think the
answer to that generally both sides of
the house says yes he did you sleep the
house the question there for us was it
inadverted or did he mean to mislead
this house let's look at the evidence
for that
first he said he first he was out first
he said there was no rule breaking get
that right first then he claimed he
wasn't aware of any parties then he said
he was outraged by the parties he wasn't
aware of then he said he was aware of
events but believed they went against
the rules then he admitted he was at
these events but he didn't know what
they were and then he was fined for
attending these events that he variously
didn't know anything about and he was
outraged over but didn't realize were
illegal then he apologized a lot a lot
again and again only a time for that
apology has passed and I'm not going to
be reticent about elections the police
have just put a statement Madam that
speaker to say that there'll be no more
issuing of fines and no more comment
until after the council elections so
this is now definitely in the mix that
the elections are a feature of all this
because of that police statement and
I'll say to my kids have colleagues with
it you've got to get a ham-hunting me
absolutely Hammer the public are outrage
now I've got a local Authority which is
conservative in Petra and we've got one
message on our leaflet which says as you
obeyed the rules the tourist parties
kick them out that will be I suspect
going on most leaflets in subsequent
elections until he is replaced and he is
removed order
um just a gentle reminder to the um
honorable gentleman that he does need to
stick to what's in the motion
people show us never dare move away from
the motion that's in front of this
housemate speaker and even the
suggestion that I would I find quite
shocking and I'll conclude with my
remarks Madam speaker this is a pivotal
moment they can they can decide to
resolve this and move on for their own
Goods as well as for themselves surely
they're not going to go down with
somebody who is so now full of contempt
from everybody across this nation this
motion won't be the end of it but it
could be the beginning of the end but I
I believe that this will only truly end
when this prime minister goes but that's
exactly all up to them
Helen Morgan
to speak I'd like to start by reminding
my honorable colleagues on both sides of
the house that I'm standing here in this
place of in this place today this
privileged position representing the
wonderful people of North Shropshire
partly because the Great British public
who we are here to represent really do
care about standards in British politics
I lost my the colleagues on the on the
opposite benches to cast their minds
back to Tuesday the 7th of December last
year and then says and the breaking
Sensational news that Allegro Stratton
had been filmed practicing answers to
difficult questions about law breaking
perhaps I remember the morning of
Wednesday the 8th of December in which
the only conservative politician facing
the media was their unfortunate
candidate in the north Shropshire
by-election
well perhaps I remember the early hours
of Friday the 17th of December in which
the verdict of the people of North
Shropshire was announced because for
them the party of over 200 years was
most definitely over
Madame Deputy speaker the motion that
has been put to this house is that the
Prime Minister may have deliberately
misled the house and as such should be
referred to the committee of privileges
we all know it's not credible that the
Prime Minister told the trees to the
house when he told us that the rules had
been followed at all times
the only possible explanation for the
claim being that he had been unable to
understand the detail of rules he'd
written himself
but I will touch briefly on some of the
other reasons that have been given to
let him off the hook
the first of course is that a fixed
penalty notice is no more serious than a
speeding ticket
I think we all know that's my best and
one of our honorable colleagues pointed
that out earlier
the Prime Minister members of his
cabinet and the country's most senior
Public Health officials appeared live on
TV almost every night to remind us of
the gravity of these laws
remind us of the importance of following
these laws from the prime minister's own
social media accounts were repeatedly
posted
suggesting that these laws were trivial
is beyond disrespectful to all those who
got us through those dark days of the
pandemic whether they were key workers
community volunteers or just ordinary
members of the public making huge
sacrifices to save other people's lives
a second argument that we've heard that
today is that the country needs stable
leadership to tackle the cost of living
crisis at home and the desperately
needed support for Ukraine abroad
well I would agree that a change of
approach is needed for the cost of
living crisis one that protects those in
need not the Super profits of companies
extracting oil and gas or ones that get
one that gives a gas a vat cut excuse me
to those struggling families not a tax
hike on the hard-working to suggest that
the prime minister is focusing on the
cost of living is frankly ridiculous
because he's focusing his behavior on
escaping from this track that he's laid
for himself
so let us consider for a moment the
grave situation in Ukraine we're largely
United across this house are the need to
support the brave Ukrainian people
sanction those who pop up Putin's
murderous Invasion force and welcome
those fleeing the tragedy of War
and we also all know that it is possible
that our leader will be required to make
decisions of the most serious nature in
the coming months decisions none of us
would be wished to force to to be forced
to make
should this happen this house and the
British public will need to have the
utmost confidence that the prime
minister is telling us the truth
Madam Deputy speaker the Prime Minister
has very irrevocably damaged that
confidence
No One Believes the Prime Minister has
told the truth because he has become
entangled in a Web of Lies
I won't repeat the timeline of events
we've heard it enough in this chamber
but it makes a mockery of all of us to
suggest that he did not understand his
own rules but the rules he set were not
broken when the police have concluded
that they were
and this brings me on to the third
argument that the public have just moved
on and that they don't care
and here Madam Deputy speaker I will
return to my opening remarks
the public of this country really do
understand the importance of a code of
conduct they really do understand that
if a prime minister breaks that code of
conduct that code says he should resign
resign to uphold those fundamental basic
standards in public life
and they become really angry when the
Prime Minister tries to bend those rules
to save himself or indeed his friends
and we'll give mine I'm very grateful
I'm a lady for giving away I mean it
could be that the police yet might have
a hand in in the trusts in terms of the
story and I think the house would look
very stupid indeed if it didn't they
refer to the the prime minister to the
committee on privileged just given those
events if you come around and in the
past they want to go to North Shropshire
on the on the on the member of One
Patterson of course I think they
regretted very soon winning that vote so
they might want to learn that they don't
want to be regretting yet again and of
course she knows ultimately for that
vote ended up on and had presence in the
House of Commons
thank you indeed I agree because my seat
in this house is proof that the British
public really do care
so if my colleagues on both sides of the
house also cared about the importance of
conserving the valued institutions that
underpin this mother of all democracies
then they would certainly back this
motion and put their names to this
motion today thank you
Paula Barker
thank you madam Mr Speaker they often
say people are products of their
environment from where I come from
empathy tolerance a sense of decency and
fairness are all characteristics that
many of our people in Liverpool hold
dear we struggle with the cell the
concepts of self-entitlement of
haughtiness of selfishness we pride
ourselves in looking down for one
another Above All Else our family our
friends our communities
by and large this is our community sorry
biologists are commonalities human
beings that they see the British people
come through difficult years
contrary to the words of Margaret
Thatcher there is such thing as society
and it's been on show each and every day
of the pandemic it's the food bank
volunteer the supermarket's assistant
the care worker the nurses and doctors
who held the hands of those dying
those who did the right thing played by
the rules as their mental health
plummeted who bit the bullet of
loneliness and separation because the
Prime Minister said that is what we have
to do
however what he meant to say is do as I
say not as I do because he was ripping
up the rules and partying
the pain endured by our people over the
last two years has left a deep emotional
scar on our Collective psyche
what the British people are now
struggling to overcome is the fact that
their prime minister is incapable of the
very sacrifices that they themselves
made
for their own loved ones for the loved
ones of our people they never met
no person like that is fit to be prime
minister of this country
Teflon has come off modern Deputy
speaker
and I'm sure the Prime Minister will
undoubtedly attempt to reinvent himself
for he covets power Above All Else
and before I entered this place
I asked myself the question why
I suspect many members across this house
did
why do I want to do this what difference
can I make
indeed I am still asking these questions
today as I hope to leave a small mark on
this place and in my constituency
I don't believe the Prime Minister has
ever asked himself those fundamental
questions the why and who for were never
important to himself he has spent his
whole life chasing power for Powers safe
and left a trail of Destruction in his
way he has no interest in my
constituents of Liverpool waverty and
the people of Oxbridge and South ruislip
will decide if he has any interest in
them
he could fall on his sword but of course
he won't
the choice for members opposites is
simple
will they do the right thing today
in the interests of this country in the
interests of the office of the Prime
Minister or will they stick with the
rotten apple
and as the prime minister is so fond of
a party modern Deputy speaker I think
the right and proper thing for this
house to do today is give them a party
he will never forget a leaving party
because anything less
is simply undermining our democracy and
not good enough
Claire Hannah thank you very much Madam
Deputy speaker um I'd attended as I'm
sure many others had I'd intended to be
in the chamber this afternoon for the
scheduled uh debate on Childhood Cancer
and it was particularly
um on the back of a very uh moving story
of constituents of mine and the long
hard Road they've been on uh with the
child with very serious cancer and I
emailed them last night to tell them
that Dr bit wouldn't now take place at
this one uh would instead and I didn't
know the family personally and I didn't
know their politics and I didn't know
whether they would be annoyed that such
an important attempt to discuss cancer
research and Care was going to be
disrupted by this attempt at
accountability but Bella's dad replied
to me saying that I hope the PM could
take some ownership for his actions for
context in the same period those parties
took place we were held to a strict one
parent bedside Rule and only allowed to
swap every five nights meaning that for
six weeks that family as they managed a
child with very serious Cancer and a
baby at home only saw each other for
five minutes every five days as they
swapped over at at the bedside and
reminded me of all of the things that
people across our countries and regions
were going through I've been very very
powerful and effective speeches from
across the houses and I must say uh
particularly welcome
um from the opposite benches to show
that this isn't a a a partisan issue and
I don't want to repeat the timeline and
all of those points about leadership and
about the distorting and the degrading
effect
um of dodging accountability and about
uh this prime minister's on Fitness to
lead at any time but particularly in
these turbulent times but I did want to
put on record in particular the views of
many people across South Belfast and
indeed across Northern Ireland who have
expressed to me their revulsion and
their rejection at the mendaciousness
and the lack of integrity and that they
have seen displayed over the last couple
of years from this prime minister and
the praetorian guard of MPS and
ministers who debased themselves and who
debase their constituents and every time
they go out and repeat the wild excuses
that are that are put before them and
members and honorable members have
pointed out politics doesn't work
without trust and without integrity and
without confidence in in good faith and
members have outlined the corrosive
effect of this Saga and politics
generally and I will just add to that
the impact that this prime minister has
had in Northern Ireland and indeed in
relationships with the Northern Ireland
and on the anglo-irish relationships as
we scramble to try and manage the
carnival of reaction that has followed
the decisions that have been taken and
the pronouncements that have been made
by this prime minister about Northern
Ireland and the gap between the
decisions that have been taken and the
pronouncements and that have been made
and by
um promising one thing undoing another
day after day by threatening every few
days to pull the pin um of article 16.
he has regressed the region I represent
and many many uh years uh by being
untruthful to and untruthful about us
whatever your views on the politics and
the Constitutional issues of the last
five years
just a reminder that we are talking
about the prime minister's conduct with
regard to Motion in front of us today
rather than going into much wider issues
paint a sketch of the impact of the cup
prime minister's character on the
politics of the region
um I represent so um I will say it isn't
as members know it isn't about the
parties although the few things I have
in common with Boris Johnson we do share
a birthday so I know exactly where I was
or order can I just say
it's the only
The Honorable lady needs to talk about
the prime minister or the right
honorable gentleman member for not using
Boris Johnson we don't refer to each
other by name apart from me I'm allowed
to do that Claire Hammer
the Prime Minister uh I know where I was
on the 19th of June it wasn't at the
40th birthday party I had intended with
family and friends like other people and
it was following uh the rules as I think
most people in this hosted this is an
inflection point uh members and
honorable members um have an opportunity
to try and put down a marker about the
long term and increasingly irreparable
damage that is happening to the public
conversation to trust in democracy and
relationships within this uh these
islands and I hope we all have the
opportunity to put down that Mark today
uh Alex Ogle
uh speaker I won't speak for long as I
don't want to delay you or the house but
merely give a perspective both on the
principle of the motion and the standing
of the house with relation to the motion
the motion for me hinges around whether
there should be due consideration by the
committee of privileges whether Prime
Ministers conduct amounted to a contempt
of this house the gravity of the charge
is great because all the hard power of
this house is to legislate I believe the
house has a great deal of soft power
disposal but that entirely rests on the
standing of this house or the public and
not just with the public in the United
Kingdom as honorable friend from chess
said right around the International
Community
once the public no longer believe the
house a place where honest answers are
given the credibility of The house's
role in public life will continue to
diminish and it has taken an awful
battering over the last two years the
hard power of the house is also
undermined as people take less notes of
the rules we make if we ourselves break
them and then worst deny knowledge of
breaking them the public rely on many
different services for our society to
function and all those serves as ability
to function emanates from the Writ given
to them by this place
during covid that was doubly important
to knew the consent of people to stop
the spread of infection I'm just going
to talk about two Services the fire
service with an incredible job in
supporting people during the pandemic
the magistrates Court which had to enact
the rules that we made they're both
Central this and I want to briefly
mention my friend Jules who served for
nearly 30 years as a firefighter and 20
years as a magistrate Julian Jenkins was
diagnosed in Non-Hodgkin's lymphoma in
2019 was making good progress in his
recovery I was in good spirits when I
saw him during the May recess of last
year with his partner Helen who I
attended University with has been a
lifelong friend
however he contacted contracted covid in
August 2021 and sadly and tragically
passed away Jules is only beginning to
enjoy his retirement after a lifetime of
public service but that was snatched
away from him now going to directly
quote Helen so I will make use of
members names but only in her words not
in mine Helen said I always feel sadness
at the loss of my partner but the moment
my overriding emotion is anger and
frustration anger Boris anger what Boris
Johnson Rishi sunaka other government
officials have done and frustration they
still won't accept responsibility if you
make the laws and immediately break the
laws you made and are then found guilty
and fined you have no credibility to
govern Johnson and Son act like any
moral Authority was essential when
making future isolation not just cover
related but in general
we need to restore The credibility of
this house and sunshine is the best
disinfectant so we must Vote for This
motion today for Jules Helen and all of
those families affected by kovid as we
are the rule makers who become rule
Breakers and we must you know and if
sorry if rule makers become rule
Breakers they must be held accountable
and that's what this house must do
that's why I must pass this motion today
Marion fellows
Mr Speaker
I just made an honorable member of this
place on the 7th of May 2015.
and I know this place means a lot to
very many members personally I have no
real interest in this place but for one
thing to represent my constituents and
to help them
foresee my vision of an independent
Scotland I don't believe in the archaic
traditions in this place
but I worked hard to represent my
constituents who elected me here
they have written to me again recently
to ask me to ask the prime minister to
resign and I have to tell them that I
have not the power to do that I cannot
make the Prime Minister resign I can ask
him I know he won't because I just
because I've asked her but I think it's
important that we pass this motion today
which may well lead to his ultimate if
not resignation dismissal
my constituents had a hard time over
covert I had a hard time over covid
which I lived mainly by myself
but I was most struck by one constituent
who wrote To Me
because she knew I was returning to this
place last June
and she asked me to go and visit the
covet memorial wall where there was
a heart up there for her mother and she
wasn't able to travel from the King
Smite institutions in motherwell in
Russia to London
that had a profound effect on me and it
also made reminded me of the number of
constituents had emailed me during
lockdown
when they missed births deaths marriages
was postponed and people just lived a
bleak existence many of them had to go
out and work in very low paid jobs
because they had absolutely no other way
of supporting their families and there
were many people and there are still
many people suffering from that lockdown
it's hard for people with privilege to
understand
how my many of my constituents lived
it's hard to understand when you miss a
funeral when nothing has happened to any
of your family
it's hard to understand how you eat out
an existence on benefits
and then when you find out that the
prime minister of this country has
broken his own laws his own rules
and has been to parties which they
weren't allowed to do or be at it's hard
it's really hard so I wasn't surprised
at the flood of emails into my inbox
asking for his resignation
yes sir thank you
I thank vulnerable to him for giving me
people right across Eastern bartonshire
are second by the prime minister's
Behavior there's my honorable friends
agree that the Prime Minister shouldn't
be trusted to run a manage never mind
the United Kingdom
yeah
sorry fellas I thank my honorable friend
amanage for those who have known Scots
it's our savings scheme by people who
are extremely usually poor who save up
on a weekly basis and if you're first in
the manage you get the total of that the
amount that is contributed
came here
yes I totally agree
I said I didn't I didn't care about this
place in some ways I don't
but there's one thing I do care about
I care about truth
as a counselor I was subject to the
Nolan principles and I am still subject
to them and not and not fantastically
I've made mistakes in my life and I
don't have the memory to lie but I think
truth especially in the prime minister
is absolutely one of the most important
things we have if we cannot trust the
word of the prime minister of the United
Kingdom of Great Britain and Northern
Ireland much as I want not to be part of
that Union then I think All Is Lost
could I therefore urge members
on all sides to vote for this motion
today
thank you Matt Weston
Madam Deputy speaker
um and I I I'm sort of reminded uh just
listening to this of of uh summer of
2019 when uh there was the leadership
election of the conservative party going
and I was surprised that a number of
people in my constituency approached me
and asked me who did I think should
become the leader of the conservative
party and and I said you know in all
honesty I I really hope that they would
support the member for Surrey Southwest
and I said that honestly because I
feared for what might happen and because
I believe that our country must always
come first
whether we're back benches at front
benches uh government or opposition
truth and the principles of law must be
steadfast and certainly if we are
occupying the most powerful elected
position in the land that of prime
minister a great public office a
position respected of course through
centuries but now uh if it is being
debased or certainly inferior being
demased the prime minister of course is
in that most elevated position of all
one that the public will always and has
always looked up to one for leadership
and through this last pandemic we have
seen just how important the role of
government and the role of the Prime
Minister is the public looking not just
for leadership but how to behave but
instead what we've seen is a public that
has reacted to that with ridicule we've
seen the memes online we've seen
children her children talking about
Boris parties online
uh
Madam speaker it's a question of
governance credibility the public know
because they saw virtually every night
on our screens or listened on our radio
and heard the Prime Minister telling
them imploring them what they should be
doing in terms of their behavior
they also saw the advertisements telling
them to obey the rules
then for months we had rumors and
speculation about how the Prime Minister
who he himself had behaved but then we
heard the counter point from government
claiming that the Prime Minister had not
misled apart Parliament or indeed the
public
what that resulted in was a corrosion of
public trust a change of behavior and
almost a position where it was
impossible to reverse what was happening
in society because they did not trust
they did not believe what was being said
or how the the prime minister or
government was behaving itself my friend
give what I will indeed I'm very
grateful to my friend for giving way and
this issue of trust I think is the uh
important point that we have to consider
today because the public have made their
minds up we've seen the opinion polls
and it's it's overwhelmingly clear that
the public do not trust the prime
minister in these Affairs but it's also
about the trust of this house and if we
are not able to police our own rules and
bring to task those that break those
rules whoever they are then that trust
that public trust doesn't just damage
the office holder of the Prime Minister
it damages all of us yes
I thank my honorable friend for his
intervention he's absolutely right and
we it is so fragile so precious this
notion of trust and for those who are
around uh in the 2000s and the run-up to
the expensive Scandal and other issues
that have have uh have affected this
house the the importance the the Primacy
of trust in this place is critical to
how it it operates so we if we are to
restore faith and trust in this place we
cannot defend the indefensible and like
the Government tried that with um the
Owen passing Affair and I really felt
for uh those members on the other side
the back benches particularly who were
humiliated by what they were LED through
by the Prime Minister and we must
restore the standards and principles of
this place and we must have adhesion to
the ministerial code which has to be
brought onto a different legal setting
I think the big distinction with earn
pass is that when outside investigation
showed what he'd done was wrong he
didn't accept it
that way I thank the father of house for
his intervention and I accept the point
he makes but I'm not entirely sure that
the Prime Minister has fully accepted uh
that he has misled uh this this place uh
anyhow if I may come back to the point
that the first offense
I yeah if the yes I'm very grateful to
my honorable friend for giving way and I
appreciate the point made by the father
of the house surely the issue here is
that persistent breaches the rules to
assumed to have taken place and the fact
that that contrast so in such an
appalling way with the sacrifices made
by the British people and that we all
expect so much better
at Western uh I thank my honorable
friend for that and I point that I'm
actually going to come on to because you
know that first offense was in summer
2020 and by then uh in Warwickshire
alone we had already had 436 excess
deaths in Warwickshire Care Homes 347
due to covert thousands of people unable
to visit their relatives and of those
many cases maybe I could just cite one
Jill her dad who had been a naval
commander in World War II a very proud
serviceman who she was unable to visit
between March and ultimately his death
in July
um the government claimed that the Prime
Minister was under exceptional pressure
well you know I think we can say that
about all the front line services all
those people working in our health care
and our teachers and across uh across
the piece uh working to to keep us uh
safe I'm sure many people here would not
have celebrated their birthdays did not
have parties they did not have office
parties I certainly didn't and I don't
believe the Prime Minister should have
at all
he certainly wasn't under pressure in
December on those matters when he did
mislead the house and as the member for
Belfast herself highlighted earlier this
isn't the only time the entirety of
Northern Ireland was misled on on paper
or lack of paper or on the borders on
the protocol and so there's a pattern
going on here that the house has to take
this one seriously it's in here it
happened
I think my own friend may be deviating
from the subject here and and I I will
uh I do want to keep this to the uh the
motion itself but I understand the point
he is making but the defenses that are
being used to defend the Prime Minister
are not really worthy of this place or
those that are Smiles them you know
ambush my cake a work event not a party
or the comparison to a speeding ticket
is I mean this is really all
indefensible uh stuff
um and then talking about Ukraine of
course we're all concerned by the
situation in Ukraine but I do not
believe that can be used should be used
as a smoke screen for the failings of
this prime minister Madam Deputy speaker
in in referring this uh to uh the
committee of privileges it is vital and
I really hope that there will be great
support on the far side because it's
essential for every one of us that we
restore public confidence in this place
and that's why of course they'll be
voting for this motion Owen Thompson
Deputy speaker and much as we said about
the prime minister's character but I
can't go there today other than perhaps
to reflect in the comments from my onto
a friend from Perth and North Persian
make the suggestion that perhaps it's a
bit less like Simba and more like scar
if we're making comparisons to that
particular film however we are where we
are and having reached out to people
across Midlothian and so their views on
this situation that's been interesting I
think if maybe it's to qualify that some
of the suggestions of their words for
this situation uh one I want to say it
simply said I have no words another said
the words I would use you would be
thrown out of parliament for trying to
use and it's not the L word
um this prime minister has broken the
law it was dragged Kicking and Screaming
to make an apology of sorts
and where all that's happened he
continues to grow his business
undermining every single one of us in
this place because his actions have an
impact on every one of us because the
public look at what happens in this
place and every one of us are tired by
the same brush
and it's critical that we have the
opportunity to hold those in the highest
offices to account
all of the law breaking criminality
evasiveness it's been able to go
unpunished not because of a glitch in
the system because in system is
inherently unfit for the purposes we
need if a prime minister was to lie
they'd be Untouchable for as long as
they've got the party on their side and
a healthy majority although given the
lack of movement on their moment today
perhaps a healthy majority could be
called into the question by some
if a prime minister breaks the law the
people are powerless to remove them we
in the opposition benches are largely
powerless to do anything about it and
it's absolutely absurd that a tiny
minority of members in this place have
all this aid over who holds that
position
so it's our system that needs to change
it's the whole system of the way this
place works and it just illustrates
to its core of how broken the system of
governance in this countries are at the
end of the day it doesn't matter who the
prime minister is whoever's in charge
has unfaird access to power and if they
don't have integrity honestly and
ability to follow the laws that they
themselves set
empowerment can't do a thing about it
it's where we are today if the
government has a majority and they
continue to support that prime minister
that is all that matters to them
some would use a an another word to
describe that but that's for perhaps
another day so yes members and bench is
opposite of absolutely have to find a
backbone and and remove uh the the
current prime minister I think many
names have been suggested for them but
we need to recognize that there's
nothing stopping whoever came next from
doing exactly the same unless we do
something about it
I don't want future generations of
Scottish politicians to be sitting here
yeah
I don't want it that's all full stop but
I don't want to be sitting here in any
amount of time having the same arguments
over and over again without yet another
Scandal of the British system
but that's what a future in the in the
UK holds scandal after Scandal and never
any justice the chaos has been non-stop
for a decade under the Tory government
for as long as Scotland is tied to this
system this chaos will continue and my
conceptions deserve much much better
than that yeah while other democracies
have matured and moved forward this
whole Saga simply shows that we in many
ways have done nothing but move
backwards
the chamber at times today has been
Furious my constituents in Midlothian
are absolutely Furious in this situation
I'm grateful to my own honorable friend
for going away and I think
in this chamber across the house
actually have heard from so many
constituents who feel that way I've had
emails from innumerable constituents and
one that I received overnight pointed
out that unbearable sacrifices that
people had made and that constituent had
lost her mother to covet and because
there was a big family and only one of
them was able to be with the mother
they've not been able to to get Beyond
this and I think that that's exactly
what we need to focus on when we're
looking at this situation I absolutely
agree with one of a friend or so many
people in so many constituences across
our countries have made huge sacrifices
to to help and support those around them
to to look after loved ones and do what
they can to help because they all wanted
to follow the rules because those rules
were in place they were just help all of
us they would help all of us to get
through the pandemic and while so many
did we have a prime minister who simply
laughed in all of our faces
I'm yet to meet a single person who
thought that the prime minister's
actions were in any way justifiable
there's one word that persistently comes
from their lips
34 conceptions have gone so far just to
email me about this someone in Anger
summoned despair but for everyone who's
written to me there are thousands
discussing it with their families their
friends and the neighbor one simply says
I fear for democracy in our futures if
this prime minister is not held to
account another I ask you to do
everything in your power to challenge
this and to convey my disgust at the
actions of his office at a time of huge
sacrifice for everyone not least the
nurses and teachers who've been dragged
through the mock and that's before we
even start to consider the countless
other workers in in jobs across our
countries who had to keep working and
just had to get on with it while the
Prime Minister parted
I just observed with less than two
percent of the conservative
parliamentary party in the chamber at
the moment it should now must be Beyond
debate that the Prime Minister will be
investigated by the Privileges committee
I absolutely agree with my honorable
friend and I think it is it has to be
now the case that the privilege
committee has that opportunity and in
closing uh Madam Deputy speaker I I
agree with the comments of so many here
today and so many who have contacted me
in Midlothian expressing disgust at the
events of the past few months it's it's
done nothing but undermine the key
principles of our democracy and today's
motion is an opportunity for us to
perhaps start to move forward from this
and to put right the wrongs of the
recent past
with Jones
thank you madam Deputy speaker and I'm
very grateful for the opportunity to
speak in this important debate but I'd
like to begin by wishing a Majesty a
very happy birthday 96 years of service
and commitment to our country in the
Commonwealth and it's my birthday on
Saturday too
thank you I was very much welcome and
acknowledge the birthday spirit and all
the best people are born in April of
course but we are not here today Madam
Deputy speaker to talk about birthdays
we are here to talk about a prime
minister who broke his own laws the laws
that he expected the British people to
follow to the letter but he had no
regard for for himself
and I'm standing here speaking on behalf
of the very many people who've written
to me about this latest Scandal caused
by the Prime Minister people like will
Foley a former constituent of mine who's
also written to the Prime Minister
expressing his outrage and disgust as he
feels he's been misled by the Prime
Minister and taken for a fall
the people of this country including
will Foley know that the prime minister
is not above the law he made them follow
those laws directly as residents in
England or indirectly like many in
Newport West
but he didn't follow them himself
we all remember how at 5 PM every day he
stood before us to recite the rules and
plead that we should follow them but
when he walked back through those wooden
doors he was partying and I have to say
I don't care if it was nine minutes or
nine hours it was a blatant and
unacceptable way to behave and totally
Unbecoming of a prime minister
I'd like the minister when he when
winding up to explain to this house and
the British people how on Earth we can
expect a prime minister to govern this
country if he feels no consequences for
his actions
and consequences for his actions his law
breaking is so important as is the truth
because the truth is absolutely vital to
what we do in this place to what we were
sent here to do because without the
truth we are merely men and women in a
Big Green Room shouting at each other
some louder than others it's imperative
that we preserve defend and protect the
truth and by proposing this amendment
the minister was the Prime Minister was
forcing his honorable members to stand
in the way of us finding the truth so
I'm very glad to hear that the
government has now changed their mind
and withdrawn it
and this motion modem Deputy speaker
isn't about partisan games it's about
doing the right thing it's about
leadership and it's about right and
wrong
this motion is about decency and respect
it's about democracy and it's about
following the law that we set this is
about good government and it's about
setting an example to our children and
grandchildren
that's why the motion table by my right
honorable friend the lead of the
opposition is supported by the leaders
of the SMP the lib Dems played comere
the sdlp and the members of Brighton
Pavilion and from North down and their
support tells you everything that we
need to know
our country is tired of a prime minister
who will take responsibility for
breaking his own laws the laws of this
land and when you say it out loud Madam
Deputy speaker this Beggar's belief the
prime minister of the United Kingdom has
been fined for breaking the law and is a
disgrace to his office and he must be
forced to face the consequences but I
say to members on the on the other side
let us help you help yourselves this
motion allows you to be objective to
ensure that the rule of law is respected
by those of us who set the laws and to
set an example
ministers are trotted out to repeatedly
refer to the Sue gray report and in her
report and I pay tribute to sue gray for
her hard work and her patience but in
her report Miss gray says directly I
quote there is significant learning to
be drawn from these events which must be
addressed immediately across government
this does not need to wait for the
police investigation to be concluded it
follows therefore that we don't have to
wait for further evidence to refer the
prime minister to the committee of
privileges at this motion states we can
just get on and do it
but let me be clear I wish we were
discussing issues importance to the
people in Newport West and across the
world issues like the war in Ukraine the
cost of living crisis and the climate
emergency to name but a few and I do
genuinely mean that but we can't focus
on those issues until this law breaking
prime minister shows the Courage the
decency and the respect for all those
who died in Newport West and across the
UK and he just goes and it's important
to all of us that he goes because as
things stand he's spending each day
focusing on keeping his job rather than
actually doing it and that's why my
constituents in Newport West are paying
more than a living memory that's why
they're struggling to pay their bills
feed their families and Heat their homes
it isn't rocket science it is simple we
have a prime minister focused on his job
rather than theirs we need a government
free of the party Gate scandal free of
Lawless lawlessness and free of
arrogance so this prime minister must go
now I will be voting today for this
motion modern Deputy speaker and I pray
to pay tribute to the leader of the
opposition for tabling it and holding
his prime minister to account and okay
sir you imagine Deputy speaker as a
relatively new member of this house I
often get asked what it's like to be an
MP and I tell people that this place is
steeped in Tradition and very often
we're having to drag it into the 21st
century how at times it can become a
little bit challenging tiring and I'm
sorry to say a little bit worrying as
well and that with no disrespect to the
clerks it can feel a little bit
dysfunctional at times as well but
there's one word that I always use and
people are so surprised when I use it
but that is collegiate that I find less
house to be at is very very best when it
is Collegiate and this dark reality is
however that less law-breaking prime
minister does no help on how
parliamentarians are viewed we know that
MPS or most of us work incredibly hard
on behalf of our constituents
but the reality is that the actions of
this law breaking prime minister further
pushes this false narrative that all
politicians are the same
my inbox is full of inquiries from my
constituents of air drain shorts and
some of them have asked me to share
their stories this one came anonymously
at 72 my dad was a life and soul of the
family 13 grandchildren whom he adored
he was young
facts but the Heart of Gold dad was put
on a ventilator on 9th of April
2020. it was eventually turned off in my
sister's birthday where he died alone
I weep every night and the sadness feels
like it's never going to go away
I sit by his grave playing his favorite
songs
my dad believed there was good and
people
and always showed compassion and
kindness to others what is happening at
Westminster has made me lose faith in
people to do good or the right thing
Aaron from airtree also wrote To Me
and he said A week before his 94th
birthday my papa Frank Bell died alone
in a care home
his memory was frail and he remarked to
his carers
he remarked his carers that nobody came
to see him anymore he couldn't
understand why none of us would come to
see him in his final hours
my papa having lived his entire life
with the love of his life was forced to
die lonely sad and from his view
forgotten by his family
of course I'm upset that I didn't get to
say goodbye however I feel Frank's story
runs much deeper a man who lived his
life with family
died alone whilst the Prime Minister and
his Pals lived with parties in
disobedience
it sickens my stomach that people tried
to pass off what the Prime Minister did
when people like my papa sacrificed so
much I would be grateful if you could
speak of him tomorrow today
not for my own pain but for the fact
that he died alone whilst the lawmakers
did as they pleased
Mr Deputy speaker when I joined last
house one of the first things I was told
it was that the mannerism was a first
place and I have to refer to everyone as
an honorable member or an honorable
friend
I'm not sure I'm seeing much honor right
now
and so
I say to those in the chamber I'll be
voting for Less motion and I say to
those on the opposite benches to think
very very carefully
because the public are watching and your
constituents are watching
Nick Whitley
Mr Deputy speaker surely is a great
privilege to be called to speak on what
most specially one of the most momentous
occasions in the recent history of this
house because today one of the most
fundamental principles of any democracy
is at stake
does honesty and integrity in public in
public office Mata
I'm out our leaders accountable to us
the people who put them there the answer
from both sides of this house today must
be allowed and resounding yes
throughout this whole Sally Saga the
Prime Minister has studied that this bus
box time and time again to deny the
breaking the lockdown rules that he
himself set
he has happily dispatched with political
advisers civil servants and government
cabinet colleagues who confess to
breaking down lockdown restrictions all
while thinking himself above them
even when challenged with photographic
evidence of him parting away while
Millions were stuck at home he absurdly
pleaded his innocence and not even the
stories of the family thrown apart
although the parenting spouses and
children who died alone could stare him
into the in the decency to come forward
and tell the truth today we are forced
to face the fact that our prime minister
the most powerful man in our country
thought he was above the law but we now
know the truth the parties happened the
Prime Minister was there he will forever
be judged by history at the first
but the first hold of his office to be
found guilty of breaking the law while
saving in number 10.
what we're here today to decide is
whether the prime minister's conduct in
this place should be referred to the
privileged committee to examine who is
guilty of consent of Parliament and I
believe that the argument for doing so
is overwhelming the time has come for
members opposite to decide where their
loyalty is like whether to the prime
minister or to the constituencies or to
constituents who put them there
for two long years we've been subjected
to the totally expectable spectacle of
concerns of members scrambling to defend
the governments as it led from Scandal
to Scandal where it's the billions
billions handed out to ministers friends
for dodgy covert contracts the Owen
Patterson lobbying Scandal or the
Chancellor's questionable saxophase but
while it's her majesty to Queen are not
our constituency to whom we Pledge Your
leaders when we first enter this place
it's our constituents to whom we are
ultimately responsible and by whom we
ultimately are held account it's how to
put that National interest first
Mr Deputy speaker my constituents can
counsel me to do the right thing by the
by them today I ask the members opposite
candy yours
you Mr Deputy speaker start by saying
and wishing her majdi a very happy
birthday not because it's just the right
thing for us to do but also we reflect
upon a lifetime of service and the kind
of leadership that always would aspire
to be able to emulate putting Duty and
self-sacrifice before the country that
she so obviously loves and has served so
very well for so many decades
um it looks as though this motion is
going to go through and so it should
what a shame we're even having this
debate this is indeed there's some
people have already mentioned it feels
like a waste of time when we should be
talking about the cost of living and how
we can help our constituents to make
ends meet and to afford the rent and the
mortgage the bills and to put food on
the table when we should be talking
about the outrageous Onslaught on
Ukraine by the evil murderous Tyrant
Putin how he can support the Ukrainian
people and so many other issues that are
equally important to each of our
communities and yet here we are talking
about this because we have a prime
minister who won't take responsibility
and it's deeply sad I think that
there'll be many offensive things that
we've heard over the last few months
most offensive is that people have moved
on can't you just get over it I had
Easter Sunday off Mr Deputy speaker and
I went to church in the morning and a
few of us went
um for uh for a beer actually in a cafe
at 11th Hall in my in my patches very
sunny as it always is in the Lake
District
um as you all know
um I've uh that might be no English
leading the house actually anyway it was
a lovely day and we've sat outside and
an elderly couple came up to me and the
gentleman said to me he said my wife's
sister died in June of 2020 she died
alone we couldn't visit her and he said
please don't let him get away with it
please don't let him get away with it
and it's a reminder that what we're
talking about here and how much is
anything else is justice justice being
done and I heard the the father House of
the house said earlier on and he was the
first of a number of people who said oh
we shouldn't be talking about this as a
local election issue somehow that is
diminishing it can I just respectfully
would you like to well please clarify in
that thing
it may have come across like that
the lead of the opposition said it
wasn't partly political
I was drawing attention to what his
colleague repeatedly said on the Today
program this morning that's all I was
saying
I think my point which I'm about to make
still absolutely stands which is that
this is only a local election issue and
it is because the party opposite have
not delivered the Justice it was in
their hands to deliver I knocked on the
door and I mean my my patch which you
know has a interesting history was
conservative for 100 years until we won
it in 2005. we've had some you know
great wins and some narrow wins one Ward
that we have never won even in my best
years
um knocking which is you know you can
argue maybe they're ahead of me who
knows but in my best years
um who knows uh a couple who told me
that they had sometimes very
conservative they'd normally voted ukip
they voted brexit party they never voted
for us they were going to vote for us in
the local elections because it's the
only way they could think of of
delivering Justice themselves they felt
they felt themselves Weak and Powerless
because they had a man who they agreed
with on many issues but who they felt
could no longer lead the country because
of that lack of integrity and it isn't
so important for us to remember it's two
years old now isn't it that many of
these things took place and our memories
can play tricks with us we move on we
don't live in the moment of those times
they were not pleasant times and we
choose to forget them to a degree don't
we but let's not forget what that meant
not just the elderly couple I spoke to
on Sunday but so many others are people
hundreds of people we know I remember
there was days weeks or weeks and weeks
on end when I wrote
um letters of commiseration to people
who'd lost loved ones and we all have
did all of us did that people who
couldn't be with a dying parent or a
dying child people who spent Christmas
alone and for many of them it was their
last Christmas then last Christmas young
children play so hard to explain to them
why their birthday party couldn't take
place all sorts of uh did privations we
went through I remember Jill Hagel
mention who is the chief exec of the
Cumbria tourism and she and I are going
to stop people persuading him to not
visit the late District even though we
knew it was ruining our economy but
because we believe in the health and the
safety and the well-being of the people
who would have come and people who work
in that Community those sacrifices that
were made the Prime Minister made laws
that we agreed with that were important
why to save lives to protect the NHS to
do the right British thing to look after
one another to love our neighbor and yet
within hours it would appear of the ink
drying on his edict he was habitually
breaking them there is no question this
was and is a resignation matter yeah of
course
it's making a very powerful Point does
he agree with me that some of the
defenses offered for the Prime Minister
have actually been hugely insulting to
those other people who worked throughout
the pandemic a dentist in my
constituency said we didn't have drinks
after work this would have been
unprofessional and irresponsible does he
agree with me it's entirely
understandable the fury that health
professionals feel because of the price
the sacrifices they made during the
pandemic that's right she makes an
excellent point and it is deeply
offensive one of the reasons why this is
a story that has not gone away is
because some of the defenses are even
more offensive the idea as has been said
from some on the other side a minority I
will absolutely state that oh well
teachers were up to it nurses were up to
it we were everybody broke the rules
didn't it well I didn't and I'm pretty
sure most people here didn't and I know
most of my constituents didn't and I
know particularly those people in the
caring professions apps absolutely
didn't and they did it they did it in
one sense gladly because we were loving
our neighbor and doing the right thing
and protecting people not because we're
slavish obedience to authoritarianism
I'm a liberal I'm not I don't like these
laws or these rules however I knew they
were necessary to protect lies and so
did the Prime Minister and yet he broke
them now look I want to just given I
think we do have a little bit of time I
won't go on for long I promise but I
want to address I want to address the
the issues about forgiveness that have
been discussed in this place and as a
Christian I want to reflect on those
because I are deeply affected by the
speech made by The Honorable member for
Wickham earlier on and some other people
who've made comments as well about the
extent to which we should be seeking to
forgive the Prime Minister now I don't
know how contrite the prime minister is
I don't know how sincere his repentance
or his apology is there's only two
beings no the answer to that question so
I'm not going to make any assumptions
that I know because I'm definitely not
one of them but this I would say and
that is I believe it's one of the most
radical and offensive things about
Christianity is that forgiveness is
available for everything and for
everyone
however even forgiven sins bear
consequences and if you look at the
Bible one things that strikes me are
that literally my reading last night was
Luke 6 27 love your enemies love your
enemies and I'm careful to not think of
people on the other side of the house or
any other party as an enemy they're
sometimes a colleague sometimes an
opponent but they are not my enemy but
there are times when you disagree with
somebody so so very much that I do so
much of the Prime Minister on so many
issues that you can in your mind make
them an enemy and I need to repent of
that so am I am I somebody who's bitter
and seeking to get my Vengeance on the
prime minister no but it would be wrong
if I did what I think we need to
remember is this that we're in forgiving
somebody we don't let them
um stay in the reputation of this place
and of our politics because to say sorry
so another you know there's the story of
Zacchaeus on Palm Sunday is Jesus comes
into Jerusalem Zacchaeus who has been a
tax collector he's ripped off his his
Keith and Ken for many many years he is
a great sinner he repents great and then
he also makes recompense he does more
than just say sorry he gives back four
times what he has taken and so I think
we need to remember that in accepting an
apology that doesn't mean there isn't a
consequence and the premise hasn't born
the consequence and in not buying not
bearing that consequence what does that
mean it sets the low for the bar so in
subterraneanly low for what is
acceptable in our public life what a
shocking example to all of us here to
all of us who might follow us to
everybody else in this country it tells
us that it's actually it's possible to
do things which are not honest it is
possible to set the rules for some and
choose that you're not going to follow
them you are somehow better than the
people that you lead that is not
acceptable that is not right what is
also not right is to hide behind the
suffering of the people in Ukraine as an
excuse not to take action now is
fundamentally weak of those members
opposite who say we have to wait until
some indeterminate time when that might
be over to take the action that needs to
be taken the simple fact is this Ukraine
is a reason why the Prime Minister
should go and should go now because we
are in a state of paralysis every
decision he takes we know he's colored
by his desire to survive and our own
position as a country we are diverted by
this ongoing soap opera this Saga this
sorry State of Affairs and the sad
conclusion I have reached is we now have
a conservative party that is too ashamed
of the Prime Minister to defend him but
too weak to remove him today's the day
they need to discover their backbone
I am now calling the last backbencher to
contribute in the debate before the
wind-ups so if there are any members of
parliament in their offices I should
really make their way to the chamber now
Florence islami
thank you Mr Deputy speaker
in my maiden speech I spoke about the
fact that it's an absolute honor to be
elected to this place
an absolute honor because never in my
wildest dreams that I think a girl a
working class girl from the council
estate in Brixton would sit on these
green benches and if I'm honest
sometimes I still pinch myself
and one of the things that I am most
humble about is the fact that it is a
privilege to be in this place
it is a privilege to serve as the Member
of Parliament for Vauxhall an area that
I grew up in an area that I went to
school it's a privilege to be able to
represent my constituents but I also
know that that word privilege there are
some things that are not afforded to me
as a female black MP
the scrutiny the Thai face
the fact that
I'm very careful in debates making sure
I State the truth and facts
because that privilege in terms of
you've been a woman sometimes you're not
afforded that privilege you're not
allowed to make mistakes you're not
allowed to mislead people
that privilege which unfortunately our
prime minister wants to continue to use
to defend the indefensible
and one of the best bits about my role
is going out and meeting the young
people in our constituency because I see
myself in so many of those young people
and those young people ask me what is it
like and how did you get involved in
politics and does politics matter
politics matters because we have to
continue to uphold the rule of law
politics matters because we can make a
difference for our constituents
politics matters because being honest
and truthful about what we are doing as
parliamentarians is a privilege
politics matters because when we work
together we can address some of those
key issues
but for so many of my constituents that
contacted me throughout this pandemic
and through the lockdown and he
continued to contact me they felt that
politics doesn't matter because they are
seeing our prime minister demean the
role and office that he holds yeah
so many members and right honorable
members have mentioned cases of their
constituents who've written to them and
I just want to quickly reference to one
of them is my constituent Jan O'Malley
her husband John O'Malley died of covert
on the 1st of April in Saint Thomas's
Hospital
Jan wrote to me when the Prime Minister
partied he made unbearable we all made
unbearable sacrifices to protect each
other I wasn't able to accompany John
when he went to the hospital or visit
him I couldn't Comfort my daughters at
his funeral and we were only able to
have 10 people there
while the Prime Minister continues to
lie about breaking the law he undermines
respect for Parliament more importantly
he undermined the public health message
my other constituent John Corman wrote
I'm a 61 year old immunosuppressed
single parent with an 18 year old
daughter we rigidly followed the rules
including my mum's funeral in 2020 with
just six people
I lost my sister last year to a late
diagnosis of stage four lung cancer all
of this was following the rule
but Florence this is a blatant deceit
from our prime minister and it can't get
clear and I can't get close to showing
my incandescent anger I feel that the
government has brought a culture where
lying breaking the law and division for
the rule of the day and I'm utterly hurt
and dismayed
Mr Deputy speaker how did we get to this
restoring faith in our politics matters
if we want people to engage in a
political process restoring faith in our
politics matters if we want people to do
the right things God forbid should we
ever come into another pandemic
restoring faith in in our politics
matters because for every person that
died in this pandemic whose heart is
painted on the wall on the covert
memorial wall in my constituency as I
wear this badge with pride it reminds us
that the sacrifices that people made
this motion today is important
it reminds us that no one including our
prime minister is above the law it
reminds us that rules are there for us
to follow them it reminds us that when
people inadvertently
mislead the house they have to ask and
be accountable and I hope that members
will remember that and they support this
motion today
wind up Central Arena
thank you Mr Deputy speaker and it's a
pleasure of not repetitive for me to
stand opposite the paymaster general and
I welcome him here today but I hope this
is the last time he's wheeled out to
defend the indefensible
on the ball and right honorable members
across this house has spoken at length
about the heart-wrenching sacrifices
that their constituents have made
through this pandemic
they have spoken about the principles of
Integrity
honesty and dignity
which are all at stake
the right honorable member for the Ronda
spoke about the special responsibility
of every MP to uphold and defend the
reputation of this house for all future
Generations
I welcome similar important
interventions from my honorable friend
the member for bethnal green and Beau
who spoke of her constituents and her
own family's painful experiences and how
they feel they have been taken for Falls
and typically value the forensic
contributions from my right honorable
friend the member for etham and
typically passionate and heartfelt the
contribution by my friend the member for
Birmingham Yardley
and I also want to welcome
the brave words of The Honorable members
for Vauxhall who we've just heard and
The Honorable member for Hazel Grove who
have made very powerful and moving
speeches State and as parliamentarians
we all have a responsibility to uphold
Democratic principles of trust Integrity
no matter what party we are from
as The Honorable member for Kingston and
Sir Britain said this is not about cake
at all but about trust as The Honorable
member for Brighton Pavilion who has
made it clear that the brutal War
Unleashed upon Ukraine is no reason to
put our Democratic standards on hold
today
as my right honorable friend the leader
of the opposition laid out the motion we
have table today seeks to uphold the
pillars of the British democracy
pillars of honesty integrity and Truth
politicians
political parties and prime ministers
will come and go Mr Deputy speaker but
the basic principle that elected
representatives must tell the truth and
act with Integrity Remain the foundation
of our very democracy
but the prime minister
and his supporters have tested these
principles to the Limit
actions speak louder than words and if
members opposite choose to stand by this
law breaking prime minister they send a
very clear message that they don't care
about their duty to uphold the rule of
law
they will be failing
to respect the privilege that it is to
serve as a member of parliament in this
great country of ours
and as a member for Wickham said
if the Prime Minister occupied any other
office of senior responsibility he would
be long gone by now
those who continue to defend the Prime
Minister are defending the indefensible
they are weakening the pillars of our
democracy
Mr Deputy speaker this is a historic
moment and today we Face a choice
this motion is about the crucial
question of whether the Prime Minister
intentionally misled the house
as my honorable friend the leader of the
opposition stated earlier the process by
which we uphold these rules and ensure
honesty in Parliament are crucial
our conventions and our Traditions are
not an accident they have been handed
down to us as tools that protect Britain
from extremism and decline
but the Prime Minister has abused those
tools as many members as outlined today
in this debate he has broken the rules
while expecting everyone around him to
follow them
and when Allegra Stratton joked about
the Downing Street parties the Prime
Minister accepted her resignation
Professor Neil Ferguson broke the rules
he resigned and the Prime Minister said
that it was the right thing for him to
do the former Health secretary broke the
rules he too resigned and the Prime
Minister tried to claim he sacked him
why does the Prime Minister think
everyone else's actions have
consequences except for his
over the last 24 hours we have seen
desperate attempts by the government to
delay distract and duck the scrutiny
they pulled every trick in the book to
kick this down the road but they've run
out of Road Mr Deputy speaker and it is
now decision time
actions do speak louder than words so
the question is
what action
will the members opposite choose to take
will they continue to defend the
indefensible
or choose to recognize this historic
moment and do the right thing
indeed
while the Ukraine situation is of huge
importance as the right honorable member
for Hazel Grove said
the invasion of a Sovereign Nation by a
dictatorial power
is no reason that we should accept lower
standards ourselves here
we expect better and Britain deserves
better
our key workers
have sacrificed so much through this
pandemic
in the name of keeping us all safe as my
honorable friend the member for
Liverpool Waverly outlined they stuck to
the letter of the rules they had no
other choice
for our care workers breaking the rules
for just 15 minutes would have risked
lives
so they can find themselves to Care
Homes up and down the country unable to
see their loved ones unable to attend
weddings funerals and births all to
protect those that they looked after
they care deeply
for the people that they care for
their value their work and they take
great pride in it and I know because I
used to do it myself
but the prime minister's actions have
mocked their sacrifice
rightly the majority of the nation feels
like the Prime Minister
disregarded and belittled their
sacrifice
as a care worker myself
I know the sacrifices that care workers
made in the pandemic on the front line
putting themselves at risk to care for
others we've all heard stories today of
how people did that
and it is the least that they deserve
for the prime minister to be held to
account for his own conduct
while the Prime Minister was partying
they were unable to be with their loved
ones in their dying moments or unable to
attend miserable funerals with only a
handful of people because of they were
following his rules
and as my right honorable friend the
leader of the opposition said earlier
they have been left after all of his
rule breaking with an empty feeling of
guilt guilt that because they stuck to
the law
and didn't bend the rules they missed
some of the most precious moments from
birth to funerals
but all those people the length and
breadth of the country had no reason to
feel guilty it is the prime minister of
this country who has broken the law and
Dishonored their sacrifice
Mr Deputy speaker many of us will be
called the seven-year-old Josephine who
sent a handwritten letter to the Prime
Minister on her birthday in March of
2020 to let him know that her mummy and
daddy had canceled her birthday party
she said she would be staying at home
because you asked us to she didn't even
mind canceling her birthday because she
wanted everyone to be okay
the next day the Prime Minister replied
to Josephine saying
we've all got to do our bit to protect
the NHS and save lives and that is
exactly what you're doing
but clearly it was wrong rule for him
and another for Josephine and the rest
of us what message Mr Deputy speaker
does that send to Josephine and all the
rest of her generation
now we know he didn't shut down his own
birthday party just a few months later
he spent it breaking the law
we have a prime minister
who is only sorry Mr Deputy speaker that
he's been found out
and today is our chance to protect the
institution of parliament at the heart
of our democracy patrons cherish our
great institutions but this week the
Prime Minister has degraded them he
wrote the rules he broke the rules he
floundered his own law he thinks the
rules apply to everyone except for him
he thinks actions have consequences for
everyone except for him today he will be
shown that the rules apply to him too
and his actions have consequences
honesty integrity and the truth matter
in politics they are British principles
and today all members have the
opportunity to defend those principles
and vote to uphold our democracy
and if they don't
I fear they won't be forgiven
I'm urging all members across the house
to do the right thing to respect the
sacrifices that their constituents made
during the pandemic and to say that the
public were right to follow the rules
and to vote to defend our parliamentary
democracy
member for Hazel Grove gave a powerful
and brave and honest speech and shown
great integrity I have known The
Honorable member I think two decades now
we go back he told us he was no longer
willing to defend the indefensible and
he drew a line in the sand
he's a man who embodies the principles
of Public Service
and I urge members opposite to follow
the lead of The Honorable members for
Hazel Grove and High Wycombe today
the prime minister
is leading the conservative party into
the sewer
it's now up to members opposite to
decide whether they follow him
it is up to members to decide whether it
is a red line
for the prime minister of this country
to break the ministerial code break the
trust of the British public and get away
with it
as my honorable friend the member for
Rhonda said the only way of getting to
the bottom of this issue and regaining
the public confidence in our democracies
by respecting the processes that have
been created to enshrine the rules of
our Parliament
although I will point out that this
process that we're enacting now today is
only in place because the Prime Minister
has failed to do the decent thing and
resign
I repeat
honesty integrity and the truth matters
in politics today MPS across the house
have the opportunity to defend those
principles and to to vote to support our
democracy Mr Deputy speaker I commend
this motion to the house
is where it was Michael Ellis
Mr Deputy speaker thank you very much
indeed and can I start by saying that
today of course is her majesty the
Queen's 96th birthday and I know the
whole house will whole house will wish
to join me in the wishing her majesty
many happy returns
now Mr Speaker
I welcome the opportunity to discuss
this important issue on the floor of the
house today and it's a pleasure to
appear opposite to The Honorable lady
the government recognizes the
seriousness of the issues under
consideration and can I say this at the
outset the Prime Minister has always
been clear
that he is happy to face whatever
inquiries Parliament sees fit and he's
happy for the house to decide how it
wishes to proceed today
and therefore will not be whipping
conservative members of parliament they
are free to vote according to how they
believe we should move forward on this
now we tabled an amendment last night
because we wanted to be explicit about
ensuring that Sue gray is able to
complete and publish her report
without any further delay as well as
allow the Metropolitan Police to
conclude their investigations we now
recognize that in practice this is
almost certainly likely uh to be the
case and therefore we are happy for the
labor motion to go through if that is
the will of the house now the Prime
Minister has apologized repeatedly
for what has happened
but he is mortified by it he wishes he
could have done things differently and
that the clock could be turned back he
has apologized as this house has heard
him do this week repeatedly for what has
happened and he has asked for The
house's forgiveness and for the ability
to get on and serve the people of this
country and delivering the opportunities
brought about by his getting brexit done
by Leading the world in covid vaccines
and the covid rollout and by his clear
leadership over the Ukraine issue
but and I would like to make clear to
the house that whilst the metropolitan
police investigation is ongoing it is
right that neither myself nor this house
speculates on the detail of matters that
are still under investigation it is of
the utmost importance that police
processes can continue without risk of
prejudice from this place or elsewhere
and whilst I acknowledge the points that
many members have made it is important
that the house understands that we
cannot preempt the outcome of an
investigation that must be allowed to
finish
now as the motion before the house today
acknowledges the proper time for the
committee to consider this is after the
police have completed their work when
all the facts have been made clear and
that is in accordance with the
principles of natural Justice natural
Justice and ancient principle that I
know the leader of the house or the
leader of the opposition understands
full well includes the principle that
allegations have to be known to the the
the the the entire
the entire person who is Accused there
must be an unbiased tribunal and that no
one should be a judge in their own cause
the member for Ronda himself mentioned
that in his view he did not believe the
the Prime Minister he has made a
judgment but
that's fine but let us be clear that
this is not a neutral uh objective
Viewpoint and it is in the interests of
natural Justice that those principles
are followed by all that is what is in
the interest of the house the leader of
the opposition spoke of principles when
he opened this motion and I have to say
Mr Deputy speaker that whilst he spoke
of principles and how that should color
the tempo of this debate his party spoke
of drafting personalized attack ads
against conservative members of
parliament and their constituencies
he also spoke with great respect he he
before before the leader of the
opposition opened this debate he
apologized to the house for unwittingly
misleading the house during pmqs
yesterday but in his next breath he
moved a motion against the Prime
Minister for misleading the house now I
say this Mr Deputy speaker the the truth
is that there is a political Tempo to
this matter now the prime minister is
currently in India as the house knows
he's out of the United Kingdom today on
his pre-planned visit to India to deepen
our long-term partnership for peace and
prosperity with a fellow leading
democracy in the face of global economic
challenges and threats from autocratic
States tomorrow he will meet Prime
Minister Modi to hold in-depth talks on
the United Kingdom and India's Strategic
Defense diplomatic and economic
partnership aimed as it is of course
bolstering our close partnership and
stepping up security cooperation in the
indo-pacific I know many members in this
house will understand that given wider
events in Ukraine it is of the utmost
importance and it has been of the utmost
importance that this important visit
goes ahead
but I want to say at this point Mr
Deputy speaker at no time does the Prime
Minister say that this issue
the issue that the house has been
debating this afternoon is not important
it is important and other things are
also of course important now at all
times the Prime Minister has set out his
understanding of events just as he did
again in the house on Tuesday and the
Prime Minister would have no concerns
with this issue being considered by the
committee if the house so decides
nevertheless
members of this house will be aware that
as I've said the government tabled an
amendment last night setting out
specifically that consideration of this
matter should take place after both the
conclusion of the police investigation
and the publication of Sue Gray's report
so that that is because the wish is that
members could have all the facts before
them before taking this decision now we
are however now content that in practice
any parliamentary process would take
place after both the Mets investigation
has concluded and that the report from
Sue gray has been published now as a
result members of parliament will be
able to vote as they see fit on this and
as the government remains committed to
publishing Sue Gray's report as soon as
possible after the Met police
investigation has concluded and I will
give way to her
and yet again I have sympathy with him
um for the back bench duties that he
finds himself
um having to fulfill he was talking just
now about having all the facts before us
will he therefore reassure the house
that all of the photographs taken by the
official photographers will also be
available to us to peruse as this as
these judgments are made so we can make
sure that we have all the facts before
us
well I can't comment on the particulars
that she mentions because of course the
batter is under police investigation so
she presupposes a state of affairs that
I cannot speak to
the Prime Minister was asked yesterday
and he failed to give it a reply to this
question but I'm pretty sure the prime
minister's human shield will be able to
answer this why did Allegra Stratton
resign
that is not part of this debate and it's
not part of my uh function here
he wishes to make political points but
this is a matter of principle uh as as
the house knows now while the prime
minister is not here he has already
addressed this issue in the house
earlier this week and as I say I'd like
to reiterate what the Prime Minister
came to this house on Tuesday to say and
as he said then we understand the
strength of feeling that we have heard
and the expectation from the public for
more from their elected representatives
that is why the Prime Minister has
apologized wholeheartedly and
unreservedly to this house
now I again would refer the house to his
statement on Tuesday if a specific
matters relating to the notice issued to
the Prime Minister but the Prime
Minister has already committed to making
public any outcome of the investigation
into his own attendance at any event
including any further fixed penalty
notices so the Prime Minister has said
that once the Metropolitan Police have
concluded their investigation he will
immediately ask the second permanent
secretary in the cabinet office Su gray
to update her findings
of her report now the Prime Minister
will of course come back to this house
to address the outcome of the
investigation once we reach that point
as the Prime Minister said
on the issue of whether he misled the
house his comments made to the house
were in good faith
he has responded to the event for which
he has received a fixed penalty notice
he made clear that he did not think at
that time that the event was in
contravention of covid rules however he
is apologized for his mistake paid his
fine and accepted the findings of the
Metropolitan Police there is a
difference between a deliberate and an
inadvertent situation and I think most
people would accept that I understand
the strength of feeling in the house but
the metropolitan police investigation is
ongoing
and once that investigation is complete
the Prime Minister has made clear that
he will return to the house uh I'll give
way
I'm very grateful to the minister for
giving away I'm confused here I have to
be honest with the minister is it the
prime minister's position that he didn't
understand the rules or that the rules
didn't apply to him what is it
his question isn't worthy of a response
it's it's quite clear he knows full well
the difference between a deliberate and
an inadvertent situation and it happens
every day of the week
so but I will say this when talking
about inadvertence I will say this as
the member for Rother Valley pointed out
uh in this house this afternoon no one
made an issue with the report in the
Times newspaper of the birthday party at
that time and that is powerful evidence
that no one believed it was a crime uh
or an offense and that supports the
assertion he asked and I'm telling him
that supports the assertion that the
Prime Minister did not knowingly mislead
the house so if he's asking for evidence
that's some of it now I would like to
close my speech by reiterating no I
don't think so I would like to close my
speech by reiterating what the Prime
Minister said yesterday that this
government's focus is and always will be
to deliver on the priorities of the
British people
we will continue our efforts to work
with our allies to face down Putin's
aggression abroad we're going to address
the toughest problems at home as we have
been doing helping millions of families
with the cost of living making the
streets safer funding the National
Health Service to clear the covid
backlog the prime minister is focused
every day on making the British people
safer more secure and more prosperous
[Applause]
[Music]
12 years the question is As on the order
papers many of that opinions say I
of the country no I think the eyes have
it the eyes have it
point about a polar Barker
smooth Deputy speaker Mr Deputy speaker
uh Julia and her daughter Daria uh fled
Ukraine as it was being bombed they
managed to get through to Poland and
they applied for a visa to come to the
UK on the 1st of April my office has
been in constant contact with the home
office who have advised us that the
checks have been completed and it was
with the decision maker Yulia and Daria
were able to board a flight this morning
to the UK to get to safety with my one
of the constituents uh in Liverpool
waiver tree they are now stranded they
have no food no accommodation and no
money we have been advised by the home
office that they should seek advice from
the consulates because there is no
direct flights back to the UK until next
week and no Visa will be with them uh
before Saturday what can I do Mr Speaker
to ensure the safety of Yulia and area
I'd like to thank the honorable lady for
a point of order and a forward notice of
it please is a very important matter the
treasury bench will have heard what has
just been said and please can I implore
that the message gets put through to the
Home Secretary in order that this could
be immediately looked at thank you very
much
question is that this
adjourn Fiona Bruce
it's a deputy speaker
on the fifth and 6th July in London
you just want to wait a moment for the
it's a lot kinder
thank you
it's a lot better isn't it
thank you Mr Deputy speaker on the fifth
and 6th July in London the largest
International Gathering to be hosted by
the UK government this year will take
place the 2022 International Ministerial
conference on freedom of religion or
belief
government representatives from over 50
countries have been invited together
with faith and Civil Society
representatives to discuss the
concerning Global trend of increasing
restrictions on freedom of religion or
belief and also it is hoped to commit to
practical steps to tackle this
a session including digital persecution
should be at The Cutting Edge of this
conference my purpose in calling today's
debate is to highlight why
millions of people each year around the
world are increasingly having their
freedom of religion or belief restricted
and to devastating impact
a key reason is the increase in
persecution by authoritarian regimes
including through the misuse of
Technology
right across the world today
people are losing their jobs education
homes livelihoods families Freedom
access to Justice even life itself
simply on account of what they believe
people are being discriminated against
marginalized beaten threatened tortured
and killed
and too often by their own governments
the very governments with a duty to
protect their freedom of religion or
belief
and the gross scale of this as a global
issue is both under recognized and under
addressed
one of the aims of this July's
conference in London is to change this
the research center Pew indicates that
83 percent of the world's population
live in countries with high or very high
restrictions on religions
the campaigning charity opened doors in
their 2022 World watch list state that
the persecution of Christians has now
reached the highest levels since the
world watch list began nearly 30 years
ago that across 76 countries more than
360
million Christians suffer high or very
high levels of persecution and
discrimination for their faith
and of course persecution does not only
affect Christians but those of all
faiths and none in Nigeria last month
the humanist
Mubarak Bala was sentenced to 24 years
in prison now on appeal
and recently the plight of Jehovah's
Witnesses ahmadiya Muslims and Baha'is
across the world have been highlighted
by the international religious freedom
of belief Alliance of 35 countries which
I have the privilege of chairing in 2022
details can be found on the U.S state
Department website
why is freedom of religion or belief so
important
we need to ask this question and to try
to answer it to set in context this
debate on digital persecution and why
addressing it is therefore so critical
freedom of religion or belief or fog for
short is important for several reasons
it's important in itself for us as
individuals because what we believe
gives us a sense of worth a purpose
meaning of dignity of identity it goes
to the heart of what makes us human
freedom of religion or belief is
important
and the importance of respecting it is
important because it is so closely
connected with other human rights such
as free speech and the right to assemble
the right to work even the right to life
itself
when freedom of religion or belief is
not respected by those in Authority all
too often are the rights crumble too
and four Freedom religion or belief is
important for communities they are
stronger including economically when
they include everyone
societies cannot fully develop when they
oppress members of minorities
freedom of religion or belief is one of
the foundations of a stable and secure
Democratic Society
countries which reflect respect form are
less prone to Violent extremism
not I believe to put two grand a point
on it promoting and defending freedom of
religion or belief is an important
element of promoting peace globally
indeed when President Franklin D
Roosevelt one of the driving forces
behind the establishment of the UN
[Music]